so da bin ich
was geht mit der musik ist das ist das
ach armes habe ich nicht gespielt keine ahnung
okay vielleicht machen wir doch was anderes
jetzt aber wir bauen heute weiter an dem tool vom letzten mal heute machen wir
tatsächlich mal ein paar apple requests und gucken ob wir auslesen können wie
lange die domains gilt ich erzähle gleich ich erzähle gleich im detail noch was zu
wenn der stream richtig angelaufen ist
heute ja heute ist kein delay heute muss doch kein delay machen gestern hatte ich
doch auch nur die latrine dass unsere gegner nicht sehen wo wir sind aber wenn
jetzt irgendjemand sieht in welcher zeile ich gerade in meinem text editor bin
ist das glaube ich nicht problematisch was bauen wir also ich mache mal kurz die
vm an vm oder wie die ganz coolen leute sagen
wobei eigentlich sagt es nur einer ich kenne keinen der vm sagt außer einen
den wir hatten bei uns mal auf der arbeit der sich irgendwann selbstständig
als konsulten gemacht hat der auch richtig plan hatte von vm wer und es war
der einzige der gesagt hatte vm wer aber es ist wie die amis die sagen ja auch
nicht mercedes sondern mercedes hat jeder so seins
vm genau
so kurz abdecken gucken ob alles alles up to date packages und so ja okay
sieht gut aus aber hier was
ja ja porsche können die auch nicht richtig aussprechen
postman wird geupdate postman und nicht post woman irgendjemand hat gedacht das
ist zu sexistisch dass dieses package postman heißt und hat dann ein
konkurrenz package rausgehauen dass ich postwoman nannte kein witz also auch im
open source bereich gibt es da merkwürdige dinger wo sich der leute
von package namen gedriggert fühlen und so was
also ich kenne also ich weiß was das was damit gemeint ist ich kann mich da jetzt
schlecht rein versetzen immer oder so was als schlecht rein versetzen also
weite ich so weit ich weiß ist das ja quasi dass du obwohl du ahnung hast die
ganze zeit denkt dass du eigentlich keinen plan hast und nur so tust als
hättest du ahnung und vor allem dass dass du die schlecht dabei fühlst das
problem ist das ist ja ist ja wirklich so also man hat von viel viel mehr keine
ahnung als dass man ahnung hat was natürlich blöd ist ist wenn man jetzt
komplett an sich selbst zweifelt dass man quasi nichts auf die reihe kriegt
also zumindest die sachen wovon man ein bisschen ahnung hat sollte man zu mir
sollte sollte man ich meine gerade wenn man da jetzt schon ein paar jahre
erfahrung hat sollte man doch zumindest feststellen dass wenn man diese sachen
von denen man selbst wenn es glaubt ahnung zu haben anwende dass es dann
meistens ganz gut funktioniert also
ja also ich weiß dass ich von viel mehr sachen keine ahnung habe als ich ahnung
habe und das ist aber letztendlich doch auch
irgendwo in ordnung dass es bei allen leuten so deswegen ich kann also ich kann
das eigentliche
die diese diese dass nicht nicht so hundertprozentig nachvollziehen weil die
grundlage dessen so nach dem motto dass man von vielem keine ahnung hat ist ja
real das hatte jeder so dass du hast du hast jeder hat von quasi wenn du sagen
würdest es gibt jetzt so einen topf so da ist alles drin dann hast du quasi kaum
was davon zumal das ja noch viel interessanter ist dieser topf was du
alles wissen könnt es ist ja gar nicht genau definiert
es gibt ja sachen die du nicht weißt von denen ist noch gar nicht bekannt dass es
sie quasi gibt und dass du die wissen könntest also es kann das jetzt erweitert
sich ja auch ständig ständig also weiß ich finde dass ich finde das an sich
jetzt nicht so schlimm wenn man keinen plan hat von vielen sachen wo es
natürlich problematisch wird ist wenn man sich dann anfängt wie gesagt auch
bei auch bei sachen die man eigentlich gut kann
in permanent selbst zweifel zu haben so ob ich das wohl irgendwie hinkriegen also
wenn ich mich jetzt beispielsweise auf eine linux kiste einloggen würde und
dann sagen wird oh je ich trau mich nicht auf den prompt was zu schreiben weil
eigentlich weiß ich nicht was passiert und die kiste könnte jederzeit abkacken
dann wird es natürlich dann ein bisschen problematisch aber ich denke wenn man
die sachen öfters macht dann sollte man noch so ein bisschen also ein bisschen
selbstvertrauen haben in das was man macht dass man das reproduzierbar ganz
gut hinkriegt weil man hat ja schon öfters gemacht
ansonsten ich ich weiß nicht wurde ja wurde die konkreten problemen ich weiß
auch nicht ob ich dir wirklich gute ratpläge zu geben kann
ich meine ein bisschen ok vielleicht kann ich ein bisschen nach voll nach
vollziehen an einer sache ich habe mich jetzt ja auf einige
stellen beworben und hatte vorstellungsgespräche ich glaube so kann
man das so kann man das ganz gut ganz gut vergleichen so natürlich habe ich in
allen vorstellungsgesprächen immer super schlau und und allwissend getan
wenn möchte sich ja gut verkaufen also sprich wenn die mich gefragt hätten
hast du tool x y z schon mal eingesetzt dann hätte ich mir irgendwas aus den
fingern gesaugt von dem wo ich denke dass sie das hören wollen und im
zweifelsfall hätten die danach gedacht ich habe ahnung von tool x y wohl ich
damit noch gar nichts gemacht habe nur dass es einmal so wie es einem der
kurzzeitigen vorstellungsgespräch geht dann wahrscheinlich bei den meisten
sachen geht glaube damit kann man es ganz gut vergleichen aber keine ahnung
ich meine ich mache linux kram und IT kram seit 15 jahren beruflich und es
gibt viele viele punkte gerade wenn ich auch mal in meine skillliste kucke ja
warum ist die window die windows suche hat tatsächlich mal was gefunden
krasser scheiß alter so gerade wenn ich meine skillliste kucke da ist es jetzt
nicht so dass ich bei jedem punkt da drauf steht dir alles so komplett im
detail erklären könnte so als hätte ich selbst programmiert also wenn jetzt hier
zum beispiel hinguckst ok hier würde ich sagen linux mäßig wirklich gut
kontinuerisierung allein schon das ist so ein großes feld wenn wir da einer jetzt
mit rancher os oder oder irgendwelchen ko es überbleibseln oder so was kommt
hätte ich auch keine ahnung von dann könnte er natürlich zu mir sagen
guck mal max du hast doch gesagt kontinuerisierung aber das heißt doch
nicht dass ich jedes daher gelaufene produkt kenne was irgendwie über bande
was mit kontinuerisierung zu tun hat
ich glaube wenn man sich selbst damit abfinde dass man von viel mehr sachen
keine ahnung hat wie von sachen wo man ahnung hat
man reicht doch eigentlich oder man ist jetzt bei uns allen so ab wann macht
programmieren spaß auch das ist tatsächlich eine interessante frage also
ich würde sagen die die meiste wo hat das dann
achter da kann ich gleich was zu sagen
ich habe geupdatet aber man hat programmieren spaß das ist tatsächlich
schwierig zu sagen also die meiste motivation beim programmieren
verspürt man eigentlich wenn die sachen so funktionieren wie man sie sich
gedacht hat ja das genau das trifft das trifft eigentlich also wenn du wenn du
irgendwas irgendwas machen willst du denkst dir was aus und nach ein bisschen
probieren funktioniert es dann also wenn du quasi zum ersten mal feststellt
das was ich mir so überlegt habe das klappt ja eigentlich ganz gut
ja siehst du und sobald man das sobald man das hinbekommen hat dann sollte man
ja denke ich weniger weniger probleme auch auch hiermit haben weil man hat ja
schon reproduzierbar sachen hinbekommen wo ich natürlich auch immer bedenken
hab ist wenn sich irgendwo einer was neues ausdenkt und dann meint so ja
jetzt überlegt euch mal wie man das machen könnte und das ist irgendwas wo
dir so denkt alter was zum teufel was will der und wie soll man das machen und
denkt man sich auch so ich habe viel zu wenig ahnung
was was willst du machen ich glaube eine sache eine sache schadet
auch nicht ich glaube eine sache schadet auch wirklich gar nicht dazu und zwar
man muss ein bisschen die hemmung abbauen zu sagen man weiß es nicht also
ich habe das unglaublich ungern zugegeben früher gerade wenn das was
ist was aus meinem bereich kam als wenn das irgendwas mit linux sagen wir mal
zu tun hatte da habe ich unglaublich gerne also wie nicht unglaublich
unglaublich probleme gehabt damit oder oder ungern gemacht zuzugeben dass ich
was nicht wusste also habe ich oftmals drumherum geredet und so was ganz im
ernst es macht auch überhaupt nichts selbst wenn du aus deinem bereich was
nicht weiß ich meine linux ist ein wahnsinnig großer bereich anwendungs
entwicklung kann alles sein unterm strich ja oder auch wenn du sagst ja ich
kenne mich jetzt im cloud umfeld ganz gut aus das kann alles sein ich finde es
überhaupt kein problem wenn man sagt und wenn man sich selbst auch irgendwie
damit dann ja so im reinen ist wenn man sagt ich habe keine ahnung ich habe es
vielleicht schon mal gehört aber kann ich dir so nicht sagen keine ahnung es
ist besser als man saugt sich irgendwas aus den fingern und die leute merken oder
hat ja eigentlich gar keinen plan also es ist es ist besser man sagt man hat
keine ahnung matte 1 bestanden porgou
wenn du dich woanders bewirbst dann schreiben die ja schon so ungefähr was
sie haben wollen da kannst du dir das ja ableiten blöd ist natürlich wenn das
so super vage ist wenn die gar nicht hinschreiben wir suchen jetzt jemand
ahnung davon ahnung davon sondern irgendwie wir sind ein junges dynamisches
team und suchen einen full stack entwickler und dann steht überhaupt
nichts dabei das kann ja alles mögliche bedeuten das müssen bisschen konkreter
sagen aber die fragen dich ja meistens auch was hast du schon für projekte
gemacht vielleicht hast du ja auch ein github github projekt und ansonsten es
ist vollkommen normal dass wenn man einen neuen job anfängt dass man sagen
wir mal das erste halbe jahr eigentlich nix sinnvolles auf die reihe kriegt weil
selbst wenn du die tools kennst ja sagen wir du bist anwendungsentwickler und du
machst java und die machen irgendwelche spring boot anwendung und das hast du
jetzt schon drei vier jahre gemacht und du wechselst jetzt deinen arbeitgeber
und die haben halt in die stellenanzeige geschrieben
wir suchen einen der sich mit spring boot auskennt du machst
vorstellungsgespräch überzeugt sie die neben dich dann erwartet doch keiner von
dir dass du am ersten tag gleich irgendwie was auf die reihe kriegst denn
nur weil du das tool kennst oder das framework kennst heißt es ja noch lange
nicht dass du weißt wie das dort eingesetzt wird ich meine nur weil ich
beispielsweise ahnung habe von linux oder ich sage mit kenn mich ganz gut mit
linux aus heißt es noch lange nicht dass ich je jegliche erdenkliche
variation und und kombinationen kenne und wenn ich irgendwo anfange komme ich
vielleicht ganz gut rein weil ich schon 15 jahre plus linux erfahrungen habe
aber wie die das dort einsetzen mit welchen paketen mit welcher software
drauf wie die das konfigurieren und was sie für vorgaben haben das kann man
doch gar nicht wissen also du kriegst das erste halbe jahr das erste das
erste quartal auf jeden fall aber ich würde sagen das erste halbe jahr kriegst
du beim neuen arbeitgeber nichts wirklich jetzt herausragendes geschissen
ja weil du einfach keine ahnung hast wie der laden funktioniert das liegt
oftmals gar nicht so sehr daran dass du von der technik keine ahnung hast du
weißt oftmals nicht wie setzen die spezielle produkte ein vielleicht ist
es auch eine andere kombination als du kennst wie sind die abläufe also sprich
kann ich da einfach mittags um 14 uhr mal kurz den package installieren oder
kommt mir dann gleich security und change management um die ecke gerannt
darf ich vielleicht manche sachen gar nicht einsetzen muss ich auf irgendwelche
anderen sachen achten wie wird die konfig verwalten solche
geschichten das weiß er erst mal nicht du kennst zwar die tools dafür aber wie
die benutzt werden weißt du nicht und deswegen ist es vollkommen normal dass
du erstmals erster halbjahr nichts auf die reihe kriegst dass er war also ich
will nicht sagen dass erwartet auch keiner aber jeder der realistisch ist
erwartet das nicht ja hello world ist ein blödes beispiel hello world ist
quasi ich will minimal beispiel in der sprache zeigen und selbst das ist blöd
weil hello world ist in den meisten sprachen außer außer vielleicht in java
und c++ ist das eine zeile
moin kannst du noch mal das domain monitor ja das mache ich jetzt gleich
wenn wir anfangen also ich zeige euch mal kurz wo wir aufgehört haben und dann
werde ich aus meinem lokalen git mal klonen ich habe ein bisschen off screen
ein bisschen weiter gebastelt dass wir heute an den interessanten dingern
weitermachen können also ich zeige euch mal kurz wo wir stehen geblieben sind wir
sind hier stehen geblieben ich starte das mal so was man hier sieht ist folgendes
wir haben ein custom prometheus exporter gemacht ein custom prometheus exporter
gebaut kann ich wieder ausmachen weil es macht eh nur fake ausgaben also wir
haben einen custom prometheus exporter gebaut der überprüft wann domains
ablaufen zum beispiel die domain wupplos.tv läuft zu diesem unix timestamp
aus und zufälligerweise wupplos.de falls es das überhaupt gibt läuft
zufälligerweise zum gleichen timestamp aus also es wird ein tool zum
überwachen wann domains auslaufen es gibt verschiedene ansätze dafür wie man
das machen kann wenn man beispielsweise mal auf shithub guckt
da gibt es solche sachen wie das hier zum beispiel domain exporter da sieht man
die idee ist nicht neu das haben schon mehr leute probiert nur mit dem
unterschied dass die das nicht so gemacht haben wie ich es für sinnvoll
halte du musst bei manchen beispielsweise domains von hand angeben und dann geht
das über irgendwelche whois anfragen was für die meisten domains überhaupt
nichts bringt so und was wir jetzt machen ist folgendes wir haben den custom prometheus
exporter gebaut also prometheus ist ein überwachungstool was metriken
einsammelt und das hier ist quasi eine metric quasi metric domain label halt
das welche domain und dann ein timestamp es ist so mit das verbreiteste
monitoring tool aktuell zumindest was was metric einsammeln angeht es gibt
eigentlich nichts was irgendwie ansatzweise verbreitet wer also
prometheus ist eigentlich mit das mit das bekannteste tool es gibt label also
prometheus exporter nennt sich das als das ist quasi ein exporter im
endeffekt ist es ein webserver der unter slash metrics erreichbar ist unsere
gewisse sachen exportiert halt exportierte schreibt halt in textform
in dem speziellen format wie das aussehen muss schreibt das rein und dann
kann es prometheus einsammeln also prometheus ist quasi eine
datenbank und ein crawler für zu metriken einsammeln
das war es auch schon wobei das an sich schon ganz schön komplex ist so was wir
jetzt gemacht haben ist folgendes wir haben ein kommando zeilen tool gebastelt
was man so aufrufen kann als parameter sagt man run und dann dann welchen
domain registrar man überprüfen will in dem fall name cheap ist übrigens noch
fake das bauen wir heute richtig in dem fall name cheap und dann gibt man
username und password ein und dann guckt er nach welche domains hat man dort
registriert und guckt wann laufen die ab also sprich dass du nie wieder
vergisst deine domain zu erneuern oder dass du mitbekommst wenn es laut dass
du mitbekommst wenn es probleme gibt oder dass du mitbekommst wenn es probleme
gibt wenn deine domains ablaufen und nicht automatisch verlängert werden die
meisten domain registrare schicken der emails allerdings emails passen und
email notifications ist so das letzte wenn sonst nichts mehr funktioniert dann
macht man das hat natürlich auch den vorteil wenn man diese ganzen metriken
in prometo ist drinne hat dann kann man sich auch schöne grafen drüber machen
dann sieht man zum beispiel ok ich habe jetzt im december beispielsweise ganz
viele domains die auslaufen und so was da kann man im vorfeld schon gucken ist
ganz praktisch und man vergisst nie wieder seine domains zu erneuern
ich bin bei ich glaube bei 5 5 verschiedenen registrarin ich habe was
bei name cheap ich habe was bei porc bann ich habe was bei billig uralt billig im
name silo ich habe petzner nitrado habe ich glaube auch noch was also ich habe
bei verschiedenen domain registrarin habe ich mir domains registriert und
will jetzt mitkriegen wann die auslaufen und ich bin mir relativ sicher dass das
auch noch mehr leute brauchen
weil alle die domains haben
möchten dass ihre domains nicht auslaufen beziehungsweise mit bekommen
wenn die domains demnächst auslaufen oder gar wenn es probleme mit der
verlängerung gibt
für den ssl check ja ssl check ist relativ relativ einfach ssl check kann
man ja von außen machen also sprich du musst da nicht über irgendwelche apis
von den registrarin und so gehen sondern machst halt einfach hatte tps web
request und guckst halt in die fälder wann es ausläuft ja aber sowas kann man
auch gut damit machen
so sieht es aus dass machen wir heute
und
so du kannst mehrere hinterlegen das ist nämlich auch was was wir gebaut haben
du kannst also was daran jetzt gar nicht mal so easy war du kannst
verschiedene parameter übergeben du kannst zum beispiel jetzt sagen ok ich
will sagen minus minus run und dann minus minus keine ahnung jetzt noch oder so
und dann da dein kram angeben also du kannst beliebig viele die unterstützt
werden angeben und was tatsächlich ein bisschen
bisschen kompliziert gewesen ist du kannst diese parameter über
kommando zeile setzen du kannst diese parameter über environment variablen
setzen oder du kannst die parameter über konfig datei setzen funktioniert das
ohne password nö ja ja ja kommt drauf an also ob wenn die jeweilige was die was
die jeweilige api von dem domain registrar für credentials braucht also
hetzer braucht glaube ich nur in api token du brauchst kein password kein
username du brauchst glaube ich nur den token bei name cheap brauchst du user api
user api key und kleint ip brauchst sogar vier sachen kommt das kommt auf
den kommt auf den anbieter stört dich denn an deine art das geht nicht an mich
gern ich habe ein view projekt auf der lokalen platte ich sehe zwei
möglichkeiten wie das auf den live server kommt einmal lokal bauen und an
pr sync auf den server oder per github anstoßen was hat das für einen vorteil
wenn ich über github gehe wenn du das alleine machst wahrscheinlich gar kein
ganz auch alles lokal machen wenn du mit mehreren leuten daran arbeitet es ist
ganz cool wenn es auf auf irgendeinem continuous integration so es muss ja
nicht zwangsläufig github sein gebaut wird da muss nicht nehmen nicht jeder
immer lokal wissen wie er das quasi verpackt und baut ready für den server
kann er durchaus sein dass er noch ein paar punkte passieren müssen
wo es sinnvoll ist doch über github zu machen zum beispiel wenn du container
bauen willst und in die container registry pushen möchtest kannst doch
alles lokal machen aber ich finde das mit github actions ganz praktisch weil du
kannst du kannst zum beispiel mit github actions relativ easy mit ein paar zeilen
kannst du container images bauen auf in die github container registry pushen
oder könntest du beispielsweise ein server so darüber neu deployen lassen
ansonsten wenn du einfach nur ein viewprojekt hast wo am ende nach einem
bild quasi ein ordner rausfällt mit html css und javascript das ist egal ob du
das lokal bildest oder in github ich würde sogar in dem fall wenn es wenn du
da alleine dran arbeitest oder sind wir projekt ist was du im prinzip innen
static web server ordner schieben willst auf deinem server dann würde ich sogar
lokal bauen weil das geht schlicht und greifen schneller und nachdem du eh nur
alleine dran arbeitest ist es auch kein ding also du musst es muss es muss eh du
machen weil es dein projekt ist dann musst du das nicht auf github actions
machen dann hast den weiteren vorteil wenn du es lokal machst also wenn das
wirklich nur quasi ein paar css javascript und html files sind dann kannst du
die nämlich lokal einfach nach dem bild per scp auf den server schieben und gut
ist fertig aus das ist die einfachste art und weise machst du irgendwie
deployment punkt sh oder sowas in den script hat drin kommt ein bild danach
macht ein scp und an den ersungen ersungen ist wahrscheinlich besser auf
das webverzeichnis und fertig das kannst du alles auf github machen aber auf
github hast du dann das nächste problem wie verwalte ich die credentials dass
ich github auf dem server einloggen kann und sowas das macht also wenn es
wirklich was ganz simples ist wo du in den viewprojekt hast was per scp auf den
server drauf muss du bist der alleinige entwickler da dran brauchst du keine
github actions was der lokalen bild in ersung und fertig ist
ich meine du kannst ein bisschen github actions lernen dabei das natürlich
vorteil an wirklich bringen würde ich sagen tut dir das jetzt in dem fall
nix also ich benutze es beispielsweise
der bild vom vier champ geht zum beispiel über github actions ich kann
euch auch zeigen was der macht das ist nicht allzu komplex
da sieht man die mit 23 23 zeilen warum geht das über github action das ist ja
auch ein projekt wo ich quasi alleine dran arbeite und sonst keiner das geht
da drüber weil es über github actions ziemlich einfach ist container zu bauen
sowohl für x86 als auch für arm also ich will ja dass das ding auf dem
raspberry pi läuft und das ganze am ende in die container registry zu pushen von
github sieht man ja hier also ich sage ich möchte images bauen für arm ich
möchte images bauen für x86 amd 64 dann check ich mein repo aus
kratzschnee war ich gar nicht doch ich checke mein repo aus dann installiere
ich dotnet version sieben
dann mache ich ein bild dotnet publish in den ordner dann mache ich ein login in
die github github container registry das ist in dem fall ganz praktisch weil
github actions schon diese variablen alles für dich setzt dann mache ich ein
image und pusht das in die container registry das ist ganz nützlich könnte
ich aber auch alles lokal machen aber in dem fall fand ich es einfacher und
angenehmer dass das automatisch passiert bei einem push auf die branches release
oder fix
könnte man auch lokal machen
wenn ihr halt richtig kacke ist und die sich quer stellen dann guckt dich
wirklich um du findest zur zeit an allen ecken was und die geben sich meistens
mehr mühe als ein aktueller arbeitgeber weil die wollen dich ja haben was ist
dann wenn man sich bewirbt sie fragen was du gemacht hast sagst du dann das
was du auf der arbeit gemacht hast oder was du alles alles naja du sagst ja
nicht du musst ja den nicht den source code von dem programm hinschicken aber
du kannst ja sagen also gehen wir jetzt mal von aus du hast an
irgendeiner java backend software in irgendeiner bank gearbeitet da kannst du
den natürlich nicht den source code zukommen lassen aber du kannst sagen du
hast du hast quasi vier fünf jahre erfahrung du hast eine backend java
backend software entwickelt für eine bank für finanzdienstleistung dazu
musstest du dich auseinandersetzen mit was weiß ich postgres oracle diesen
libraries diesen frameworks und musstest nach scrum arbeiten und hast
irgendwie erfahrung mit agilen entwicklungsmethoden und bla bla bla bla
bla du kannst ja du kannst ja schon beschreiben was du gemacht hast ohne
den source code zu schicken ja und ich würde auch also wenn du
github account hast würde ich auf jeden fall mit schicken gerade wenn du dich
als entwickler bewirbst und auch wenn es um technologien geht würde ich auch
sachen sagen wo ich mich privat mit beschäftigt habe warum nicht ja wenn ich
mich beispielsweise mit volumi oder sowas beschäftigt habe das habe ich ja
nicht auf der arbeit gemacht das habe ich hauptsächlich privat gemacht habe ich
trotzdem in meine skills reingeschrieben warum nicht wenn ich habe mich damit
beschäftigt ob ich jetzt auf der arbeit gemacht habe oder privat ist erst mal
egal
ja kannst du machen
genau so sieht es aus wenn du in github repo link hast ist natürlich noch
besser
ist mit motivations schreiben ein klassisches anschreiben bei bewerbung
gemeint ich bin kein personaler ich kann personaler speak nicht ich weiß nicht
genau was sie damit meinen aber ich würde schon sagen ja ich weiß zum
beispiel das toh man ist ein musik shop denk mal den kennen viele so mit der
bekannteste shop für instrumente und und audio equipment dass die an
motivations schreiben haben wollen beziehungsweise gucken wir doch mal mal
gucken ob die das noch auf auf ihrer webseite stehen haben
agile coach aber vielleicht irgendwas technologie also die haben die haben
hier drin drin immer stehen gehabt vorher nee haben sie nicht mehr drin stehen die
hatten eine ganze weile drin stehen dass du quasi ich weiß nicht mehr wie sie es
formuliert haben so dass du deine leidenschaft zur musik und sowas in der
bewerbung zum ausdruck bringen sollst also sie wollten wissen ob man irgendwie
was was damit am hut hat und ansonsten ja keine ahnung was sie da hören wollen
meine motivation ist geld verdienen kann man da wahrscheinlich nicht
reinschreiben auch wenn es die wahrheit ist weil wahrscheinlich dann der
personaler sagt so nach dem motto aber nicht die die wörter gebracht die ich
hören will meine motivation ist nicht unter der
brücke schlafen zu müssen es zählt wahrscheinlich nicht auch wenn es die
wahrheit ist ja
ich meine motivation ist essen im kühlschrank für meine familie und mich
das motivations schreiben wäre zusätzlich keine ahnung also ich habe
gar kein anschreiben hingeschickt gab es einfach hochgeladen aber das war ja auch
klar im vorfeld weil ich habe ja mit denen schon telefoniert
getup actions erstellt dann das ganze docker image das ist dann relativ groß
es geht so groß ist das glaube ich gar nicht das ist ja das ist ja ein alpine
image gucken wir mal wie groß die images sind falls es dabei steht das image ist
so ich bin das irgendwo
ob sei das 24 mb
Ne, das müsste man jetzt runterladen, ich hab keine Ahnung wie groß das Image ist.
Es ist aber nicht groß, das ist ein Alpine Image mit meiner Software drinnen, was wird
denn das am Ende sein?
30, 40 MB oder so und das größte davon ist das gebundelte.NET Framework.
Ich mein das macht ja nicht wirklich viel, guck das macht ein Alpine Image, sieht man
jetzt hier nicht, aber ich weiß, dass es das ist, da packts mein Programm rein.
Ne, so groß ist das nicht, Alpine Images sind meistens nicht, sondern nicht groß.
Machst du noch ein paar Stunden, ja ich hab noch gar nicht richtig angefangen.
Ja also wenn man keine Probleme hat zu schleimen, weil man den Job haben will, kann man das
machen.
Ein bisschen denen erzählen, was sie hören wollen, ist doch ok, ok nice wir haben es
geschafft.
So, switchen wir mal rüber, also das ist das, das ist das, was wir das letzte Mal programmiert
haben.
Das ist ein Commando Zeilen Tool, wo du angeben kannst, was du checken möchtest, also welche
Anbieter du das Ablaufen überwachen möchtest von deinen Domains und dann klickst du das
ganze per Prometer als Exporter zur Verfügung gestellt.
So, ich werde das hier mal kurz löschen, denke mal ich kann das löschen, glaube ich
brauche da nix mehr von, ich benenne es mal um, so Mainchamp, so Mainchamp old, immer
beste.
Wisst ihr was lustig ist, ich habe ja letztens wieder ein neues Notebook gekriegt auf der
Arbeit und ja das muss ich mal kurz zumachen und da musste ich mal wieder mein Heimatverzeichnis
umziehen, Linux technisch und dann ist mir mal aufgefallen, ich habe mittlerweile fünf
Verschachtelungen von Home, ich habe also quasi im Durchschnitt so alle drei Jahre
einen neuen Laptop gekriegt, ich habe Max Home, Max Home old, in Max Home old, ist Max
Home old, Max Home old, old, old, old, fünffache Verschachtelungen mit Old Home, ich habe mal
geguckt, mein eigentliches Heimatverzeichnis ist keine Ahnung, nicht groß, irgendwie 8G
oder so, da liegen auch sehr viele unsinnige Downloads drinne, aber insgesamt ist mein
Heimatverzeichnis eigentlich an die 50 Gigabyte groß, weil ich über 15 Jahre lang mein Heimatverzeichnis
immer mitgenommen habe, Older Home, Oldest Home, am Oldesten Home, noch Older Home, aber
das hat sie eh bald erledigt, dann fliegt das alles weg, so ich muss mal kurz klonen
von meiner lokalen Kiste, Domainchamp, da sind wir, Ryder, Domainchamp, alles klar,
Program, übrigens Ryder, sieht so komisch aus, weil Ryder ein neues UI hat, Problems,
was willst du von mir, was jetzt, hat er nicht die richtige C-Sharp Version vielleicht, C-Sharp
11, easy, jetzt funktioniert es, ok, also ich werde euch mal ganz kurz, bevor wir loslegen,
ein bisschen zeigen, was ich jetzt noch umgebaut habe zum letzten Mal, ist tatsächlich relativ
übersichtlich, guckt mal, man hat nicht viel, ich mach mal die Schrift, ich mach die Schrift
kurz ticken kleiner, dass ein bisschen mehr auf den Bildschirm passt, also es ist nach
wie vor eine Konsolenanwendung, man kann zum Beispiel sagen,.net run, könnt ihr mal ausklammern,
das ist einfach nur zum starten, bevor ich ein Package gebaut hab, oder warst du jetzt
15 Jahre bei der Bank, nee, war ich nicht, hast du dein Home von der alten Arbeit zur
neuen mitgenommen, in dem Fall schon, ja, aber jetzt mach ich das nicht, also liegt
daran, muss ich vielleicht mal erklären, wissen ja nicht alle, bzw. ich hab das zwar schon
oft erzählt, aber es kann nicht jeder mitgekriegt haben, also ich war nicht 15 Jahre bei der
Bank, ich hab erstmal ne Ausbildung beim Provider gemacht, dann hab ich noch ein Jahr beim Provider
weitergearbeitet, dann hab ich bei der Bank gearbeitet, aber der Weg, wie ich da hingekommen
bin, also zur Bank, war, weil der Provider, bei dem ich gearbeitet habe, oder der Provider,
oder ich kann selbst in diesem Video nur kurz gesagt, nee, wie geht das in diesem Video
nur, nur ganz kurz, in diesem Video nur ganz kurz, also zumindest der Provider, bei dem
ich gearbeitet hab, der hat IT-Dienstleistungen für die Frankfurter Bank gemacht, bei der
ich jetzt arbeite, also bei der ich noch, bei der ich noch arbeite bis 31.3., oder 30.3.,
Januar, Februar, jetzt 31.3., und ich hab, als ich dort gewechselt bin vom Provider zur
Bank, und ich quasi eh fast exklusiv schon für die Bank gearbeitet habe davor, hab ich
das Heimatverzeichnis mitgenommen, jetzt werd ich das nicht machen, jetzt kann ich das gar
nicht machen, weil ich, also ich werd ein bisschen Konfig mitnehmen, die ich mir so zusammengebaut
hab die letzten Jahre, aber nichts von der einen Firma in die andere, das darf ich ja
auch gar nicht, weil ich auch gar nicht das Laptop mitnehmen kann und sowas, nee nee,
das mach ich nicht, aber in dem Fall war das weniger ein Problem, das war ja, ich hab ja
beim Provider gearbeitet, dann bin ich zur Frankfurter Bank gewechselt, aber ich war ja
vorher schon mehr oder weniger dieses Jahr komplett in Frankfurt bei der Bank und hab
quasi exklusiv zu 99% für die gearbeitet das Jahr schon, und danach gabs halt die übliche
Geschichte, die ich jetzt hier in dem Video breitgetreten habe, hier, da gabs dir dieses
Video, wenn der Chef dich verarscht, da hab ich ja über meine Erfahrung damals bei diesem
kleinen Klitschen Provider, wobei so klein ist der gar nicht, da hatte ich damals auch
schon über 100 Mitarbeiter, aber für Providerverhältnisse mag das klein sein, über meine
Erfahrungen, die hab ich schon ein bisschen berichtet, und nachdem die es da total übertrieben
haben, bin ich ja dann zur Frankfurter Bank gegangen, wo ich vorher schon quasi tagtäglich
gewesen bin, hab dann halt direkt bei denen angefangen.
So war das, so sieht das aus, kann vor allem bei Workstation eigentlich PCI-Geräte durchreichen?
Nein, kanns nicht, leider, es wäre sehr cool, wenn es das könnte, technisch ist das wahrscheinlich
sogar irgendwie möglich, möchte man wahrscheinlich, Hyper-V kanns ja glaub unter Windows 11 auch,
oder Windows 10, also ab Windows 10 beginnend, kann das Hyper-V glaube ich auch irgendwie,
also technisch wärs wahrscheinlich möglich mit irgendwelchen Windows-Könnel-Treibern
und haste nicht gesehen, unterstützen sie aber nicht, wahrscheinlich ist es auch schwierig,
das, das Ride zu gapen, das unter Windows, also geht nicht, es wär auf jeden Fall sehr
cool, wenn das gehen würde, man kann das manchmal ein bisschen umgehen, wenn man PCI-Geräte
durchreicht, manche PCI-Geräte, äh nicht PCI-Geräte, was erzähl ich denn, USB-Geräte,
also manche Geräte gehen ja über USB und da ist es ganz sinnvoll, auf mal sie durchzureichen,
beispielsweise eine Soundkarte oder so, wenn man das braucht, aber GPU-Pass-To ist schwierig,
GPU-Pass-To mit manchen vor allem auch soll das eigentlich sein, nee, nee, nee, du kannst
keinen GPU-Pass-To, du hast ja nicht mal irgendwelche Optionen dafür in das Forever Workstation,
du kannst das beispielsweise, logischerweise im ESX machen, du kannst das mit Hyper-V machen,
du kannst das mit KVM machen, du kannst das wahrscheinlich auch mit VirtualBox und Linux
machen, aber Forever Workstation kann das nicht und unter Windows schon mal gar nicht,
leider, es wär auf jeden Fall wirklich cool, wenn sie das könnte, also das wär sehr nice,
wenn das gehen würde.
Ich glaub, der einzige Grund, VirtualBox zu benutzen unter Linux ist Desktop-Virtualisierung,
weil grafische Software läuft nicht gescheit in KVM, also die läuft, aber es macht keinen
Spaß, das Ganze zu bedienen, also die grafische Ausgabe in VirtualBox ist viel, viel flotter
als beispielsweise über den Wirt-Manager und dann über LDP, selbst Spice, das ist
alles Müll, also VirtualBox ist da deutlich, deutlich zackiger, auch wenn man ein bisschen
3D-Beschleunigung in der VM braucht, geht das, okay, das kann sein, hab ich schon eine ganze
Weile nicht gemacht, ja, du hast recht, dann stimmt es nicht mehr, was ich sag, das hab
ich noch gar nicht ausprobiert, weil ich mach keine Desktop-Virtualisierung unter Linux
mehr, schon lange nicht mehr, stimmt, du hast recht, ja, da war was, also unter Linux geht
das, unter Windows kannst du es knicken, okay, weiter, also wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Genau, ich wollte euch mal ganz kurz ein bisschen zeigen, wie ich es jetzt umgebaut hab, also
das, was ich euch eben gezeigt hab, ist das, was wir, was wir das letzte Mal gebaut haben,
kann diesen ganzen Krempel gleich mal aufräumen hier oben und jetzt das, was ich offstream
schon ein bisschen umgebaut hab, dass wir uns heute um die Checks kümmern können, also
es ist nach wie vor eine Kommando-Zeilen-Anwendung, die hat, kann es euch zeigen, zwei verschiedene
Kommandos, was, achso, also die hat zwei verschiedene Kommandos aktuell, unsere Anwendung, später
wird man das, übrigens jetzt ruf ich das mit.NET Run aus, auch später wird man das
so aufrufen, ja, gibt's aber noch kein Package, also du hast zwei verschiedene Kommandos,
List und Run, List gibst du alle supportenden Domain-Registrare aus und mit Run startest
du den Exporter, List macht aktuell noch nichts wirklich Sinnvolles, wenn ich List mache,
hab ich ein bisschen Infos, die ich hab ausgegeben, das natürlich noch nicht richtig formatiert,
und wenn man sagt Run, dann sagt er, ja gut, dann wird er sagen, ja, du hast ja nichts angegeben,
was du haben willst, ich kann aber erst auch schon einen Hilfetext, Hilfetext aufrufen
für Run, das seh ich jetzt, ok, aha, aktuell wird anscheinend plus Namecheap als Provider
unterstützt und ich könnte das jetzt hiermit aufrufen, ich könnte jetzt sagen Run, minus
Minus AP User, bla bla bla, Minus Minus Username, bla bla bla, Minus Minus, bla bla bla, so
kann ich das aufrufen und dann wieder abkacken, weil er sagt, aha, dieses Argument sieht nicht
nach einer IP-Adresse aus, also ok, jetzt sieht's nach einer IP-Adresse aus und jetzt
funktioniert das Ganze auch, aber wir sehen schon, ok, so ein bisschen Validation macht
da auch schon, AP User or Username must be set, was komisch ist, weil ist es eigentlich,
da muss ich mal gucken, was ich da verkackt habe, AP Key muss gesetzt sein und die IP-Adresse,
so, und das kann ich jetzt für alle anderen auch aufrufen, also sprich, wir haben eine
Kommando-Zeilenanwendung, die wir mit Plugins erweitern können, das ist ja das, warum das
ein bisschen komplizierter war das letzte Mal, ich möchte ja, dass man diese Domain-Registrare,
dass man pro Domain-Registrare quasi so ein Plugin hat, jetzt haben wir ein Plugin für
Namecheap, dann könnten wir noch ein Plugin für Hetzner und sonst was machen und die
sich automatisch hier in der Kommando-Zeilenanwendung registrieren, dass man nicht irgendwie immer
im Main-Programm rumwürsten muss und diese ganzen Optionen eintragen, ja, ich könnte
übrigens die ganzen Parameter auch so setzen, guckt mal, ich zeig's euch mal, also wir machen
jetzt hier, AP User Kecke, man sagte, ah nee, da fehlt ein bisschen was, aber ich könnte
auch, ich hab irgendeinen, ich hab irgendeinen, oh ich glaub ich weiß, was ich gemacht hab,
ich bin, ich bin ja auch blöd, guck mal, kann doch gleich sagen, was ich gemacht hab,
übrigens der Attire ist noch falsch, müsste Namecheap heißen, ich kann euch sagen, was
ich falsch gemacht hab, guckt mal hier, ist null a white space und wenn beide leer sind,
upps, also, äh, ok, hä, es sollte eigentlich jetzt gesetzt sein, was auch immer, ok, also
das ist eigentlich nicht das, was ich zeigen wollte, ich könnte jetzt aber die Sachen
auch per Environment Variable setzen, also ich kann zum Beispiel dann sagen, ähm, sowas
hier, gleich User, upps, wenn ich, weil ich das richtig schreibe, wäre natürlich ganz
sinnvoll, kann das per Environment Variable setzen, jaja, oder per CLI, oder per config
File, upps, ne, ah, oder ist ja richtig clever, der checkt sogar, wenn die Sachen doppelt
gesetzt sind, Pipehead Time, jo, und das probieren wir jetzt mal aus, und der Rest ist eigentlich
relativ einfach zu erkennen, also, er guckt erstmal, ob er Checks findet, dann guckt
er, ob die Inputparameter stimmen, wenn nicht, gibt er ne Warnung aus und dann führt er
den Kram aus, pernisch aus, so, und was ich jetzt, wie viele Leute arbeiten an diesem Projekt,
ich, sonst keiner, so, und was, was ich jetzt mal ausprobieren wollte, also, muss man zugeben,
ist relativ übersichtlich noch, was ich jetzt mal ausprobieren wollte ist, wir machen mal
tatsächlich ein paar API-Requests, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was,
der Chat, schreibt wieder komische Sachen heute, manchmal ist der Chat zu High IQ, da
da wäre ich nicht schlau draus so zumindest werden wir uns jetzt mal einen fake account
machen hallo warte wenn ich da drauf klicke passiert nix wenn ich da und da drauf klicke
ok aber wenn ich hier drauf klicke passiert nix passiert nix was das das scheint mir
ein bug in die 3 zu sein oder das ist doch ein bug in die 3 das ist mir noch nie aufgefallen
ich meine normal aber ich schalte eigentlich so gut wie immer mit tastatur um ich klicke
eigentlich nie hier oben durch deswegen fällt mir das nicht auf ernsthaft man kann da nicht
drauf klicken man manchmal gehts und manchmal gehts nicht ganz ganz weird weird champ so
wir machen uns jetzt mal einen fake account bei namcheap muss übrigens mal kurz gucken
ob ich mich auf meine test test hetzner kiste verbinden kann seck ja ja alles klar kann so
funktionieren von da prob von da probieren das klein mal aus du bist daran zwei stunden
verzweifelt ok also bin ich nicht der einzige der den bug hat ok wir werden gucken die drei
klicke hörst ja wir wie heißen das desktop klicke erst eiken workspace heißt das klicke
first workspace es ist egal wo du klickst also es geht manchmal manchmal geht es auf
dem eiken guck jetzt gehts auf dem eiken wieder nicht und nach dreimal klicken geht
es wieder aber es ist nur auf dem ersten desktop es ist ganz komisch ok aber es geht nicht
immer auf dem eiken aber wenn es geht dann geht es auf dem eiken sehr sehr sehr merkwürdig
es hat mit dem eiken nichts zu tun hier hinten gehts auch hier hinten geht es übrigens immer
es muss irgendwas mit ab hier geht es nicht was es nicht alles gibt
nee es funktioniert hier auch es funktioniert hier auch hier ist gar kein eiken lustig was
keine ahnung wir könnten aber mal ich meine ich habe immer noch i3 gaps glaube ich was
wir eigentlich ich müsste mal ich müsste mal das normale i3 wieder installieren weil
ich habe eigentlich also ich habe zwar i3 gaps aber i3 gaps gibt es nicht mehr also
i3 gaps wurde gemerged in i3 und dementsprechend könnte ich eigentlich wieder i3 installieren
jepp
ja aber das wird nicht an dem eiken selbst liegen sondern dass da irgendwas wenn ich
ein anderes eiken nehmen würde gehts wahrscheinlich auch nicht keine ahnung es muss entweder
eine vmware geschichte sein wobei ich nicht weiß irgendjemand im chat hat gerade geschrieben
dass es bei ihm auch so ist weiß ich ob er das in vm betreibt oder nicht sehr merkwürdig
na gut also wir registrieren jetzt mal einen fake account in der namecheap sandbox registrieren
uns da mal eine domain und machen abfragen wir machen mal kurz achtung leute so schlimm
ist die seite gar nicht sandbox account login fake account fake account time sign in sign
up wichtig ist wir sind in der sandbox ja 10 minute mail also mit der sandbox ich finde
es übrigens ganz gut dass die in der ap sandbox haben da kann man registrieren was
man will und hat 9000 dollar gut haben gut haben fake fake dot achso das ist der user
username naja so das so will ich heißen das beste username überhaupt nein das password
zeige ich euch nicht das password muss ich mir hier kurz aufschreiben ok excellent first
name heta null email adresse das hier kein newsletter please don't save oh oh bin ich
human parking meters ja excellent muss all seriously soll ich den scheiß jetzt nochmal
tippen ok create account jetzt please funktioniert gut und jetzt kann ich mir domains registrieren
also die domains die sind natürlich jetzt nicht für euch erreichbar weil das alles
in der sandbox ist also quasi fake domains aber wir können domain registrieren und dann
über die ap zeug abrufen ich würde sagen wir gehen erstmal in die ap rein wir schalten
erstmal die ap die ap ein tools aber wo haben sie das versteckt ja ap exes ap exes turn
on yes in den kram muss ich heute wahrscheinlich öfters schreiben ist ja ich save erstmal
ok ap key omg leute ap key liegt von der sandbox jetzt ist vorbei
liegt monka omega x so white list ap white list ap nein weder das noch das andere white
list ap kecke da brauche ich die von meinem server weil von da werde ich das ganze jetzt
gleich ausführen und da kommt ja außer mir keiner drauf ja ja save changes nein das ist
eh die sandbox so jetzt brauchen wir noch irgendeine domain zum ausprobieren domain
das schon alles aufgebraucht ja guck mal wir haben 9.000 euro fake gut haben jetzt domains
ja lass mich eine domain registrieren please find your new domain name cute chat punkt
xxx wie die gibt es nicht na doch doch gatschi bus endlich wollte immer cute chat punkt
xxx haben by the way diese domain wird jetzt nicht wirklich angelegt das ist alles fake
nummer so wir sind in der sandbox da kannst du da könnte ich wahrscheinlich sogar google
anlegen und es würde nichts passieren das will ich alles nicht haben nervt nicht hier
rum check out domain privacy ja genau domain registration ein ja wunderbar ja confirm ok
wir sind peter lull omega lull omega lull private address ok zeil fünf in frankfurt
ich möchte random singen aber wahrscheinlich haben sie ein poster zahl ok poster zahl check
trinne fake essen essen ja telefonnummer lull fax ich brauche noch zehn minuten länger
ich werde mal mein account bestätigen weil es durchaus ne muss man gar nicht bestätigen
bestätigt mal mein account weil sonst weiß man ja nie ok ganz toll next die gibt es
wirklich für den preis jaja das kann sein aber ich will sie ja gar nicht haben so user
default contact alles ganz toll oh nein xxx domain moment wir brauchen extra
brauchen wir irgendwelche extra sachen um xxx domains egal das wird auch wieder auch
so wird auch so funktionieren hoffe ich mal wenn ich muss der andere domain registrieren
nein nein nein nein ich will keine ich will keine karte hinzufügen account funds will
ich benutzen wir haben nämlich 9000 fake dollar auf unserem account
jaja ok next gut pay now check out of two items moment was für two items ich hab doch
nur ich hab doch nur eine domain gekauft ach free domain privacy ok alles klar alles klar
na dann ok schauen wir mal unsere domains an was wir haben profile domain list da sollte
es jetzt drinne stehen cute chat punkt xxx wie gesagt alles alles fake gibt es nicht
na gibt es nicht aber was ich jetzt machen kann ist ich gehe mal auf meine auf meine
netzner kiste drauf wie gesagt gibt es nicht ich zeige es ist auch gut so ansonsten wird
es ja wirklich geld kosten so und jetzt machen wir mal einen api request und schauen ob das
funktioniert bevor wir das von dort net aus machen also ich habe in der inbox name cheap
api tools api ich finde es nicht die seite ist so hässlich immer aufgebaut man hier
manage api documentation alles klar send box api sehr xml xml sehe ich das richtig ist
denn ihr oh nee oder wir müssen jetzt keinen xml machen jetzt jetzt jetzt verarscht mich
nicht sample api call ok wir machen wir machen einen sample api call schau wir machen mal
einen karl api call und gucken wie das funktioniert bevor wir es in dort net machen xml man boar
please ok xml api user api user ist wahrscheinlich mein username oder ich weiß es nicht api user
api key api key habe ich api key ist das da username ist wahrscheinlich der gleiche der
gleiche mist noch mal client api ne ne ne client api ist das da command name cheap domains
arrows ja gut die domain gehört ja auch nicht mehr domain list cute chat punkt xx ach moment
ok es scheint zu funktionieren es scheint alles zu funktionieren jetzt können wir mal gucken
wie man was abfragt wie die wie die start wieder status von der domain ist also wann
die wann die expired will ich hier abfragen get list also wir listen mal alle unsere domains
auf ist ich brauche einfach nur command name cheap domains get list command muss ich das
mit kopieren ja ok command gleich ok cute chat da sind wir cute chat punkt xxx user
things created da expires da da haben wir schon alles was wir brauchen aber muss es
wirklich xml sein ich meine er hätte es nicht hätte es nicht irgendwas anderes sein können
als xml müssen die uns wirklich quälen mit irgendwelchem xml chat jetzt was ist an xml
so schlimm naja guckt ihr das mal an wer kann das lesen richtig monach s hyper monach
s xml gut also wir wissen jetzt was wir für einen request machen müssen diesen diesen
request müssen wir im endeffekt mal ganz ganz easy so dann gucken wir mal wir bauen das
mal ein also das ding soll übrigens ich names name silo check sein sondern wir müssen mal
kurz sagen tools nee doch edit rename ok name cheap alles klar gut also ich muss mal
kurz mal mal hier ausgeben ob da wirklich kein happy user reinkommt sehr merkwürdig
schwer happy user doch richtig so value ist zum string kackel doch so alles gut und warum
ist jetzt der mein wahrscheinlich habe ich hier irgendeinen müll programmiert append
error if ja ist überhaupt kein if drinnen low high IQ max wahnsinnig super high IQ gemacht
append error if und keine if drinnen ganz schlau jetzt gibt es jetzt gibt es auch sinnvolle
jetzt gibt es auch sinnvolle fehlermeldung ob ich das so lasse weiß ich nicht ok also
dann dann dann befüllen wir das hier doch mal mit sinnvollen mit sinnvollen infos also
es wird übrigens nicht funktionieren sage ich gleich weil ich ja nicht von der hetzener
kiste ausführe wir führen es dann aber gleich von der hetzener kiste aus also usernamen
ist so und wisst ihr was das coole ist jetzt dadurch dass ich das per dass ich die plugins
einzeln registrieren kriege ich auch eine schöne hilfe hilfe ausgabe dafür das heißt
ich kann jetzt ich kann jetzt hier an ok der hilfetext ist noch ein bisschen bisschen
falsch ich kann jetzt angucken was brauche ich dann ok ich brauche ein argument name
cheap ap user name cheap usernamen ap key und klein ip brauche ich ich sehe sogar den
typ dahinter was ich angeben muss ja string string string und das muss eine ip adresse
sein usernamen lasse ich weg der ist optional ap key ap key habe ich ap key ist der da und
klein ip habe ich auch klein ip ist die hier ja ist gut soll das wird jetzt nicht funktionieren
aber wir sehen schon was ist alles gesetzt er kackt nicht mehr ab schon mal gut gut zu
wissen soll wir brauchen ein muss ich das mal so erweitern das passt also wir haben
irgendwie user haben key und wir haben ip so kein ip adress array ip aber ich das ganze
nehme ich mal zuweisen user ap user es kann null sein jetzt macht ja es kann juridisch
alles null sein wenn ich richtig gesetzt das das wollte ich mir gleich überlegen mich
dass ich das gescheit mache so dann haben wir jetzt den key value und wir haben ip wunderbar
so das brauchen wir nicht mehr gibt es nicht mehr und das ist run also wenn alles funktioniert
sollte das hier jetzt aufgerufen werden und hier kann ich mein web request drinne machen
ja funktionieren soll der web request sollte natürlich fehlschlagen probieren probieren
das mal aus der web request sollte fehlschlagen weil ich komme ja nicht von der richtigen
absender ip also probieren wir das mal aus hatte tp kleint anju hatte tp kleint hatte
tp kleint get string async wir machen jetzt mal ganz hardcoded den kram da reingeschrieben
jep a weight result und das geben wir jetzt mal aus result soll mal gucken was passiert
result error xml shit oh nein ip leak momks leute lasst eure bots please stecken hab ich
keinen bock drauf dass ich jetzt den stream neu anmachen muss so jetzt können wir das
eigentlich über den hetzer server machen jetzt werde ich das ganze rüber erst und
dann gucken ob es funktioniert weil dieser request sollte von der hetzer kiste aus funktionieren
also machen wir das doch mal hier root nee warte mal ich sollte ich sollte es eigentlich
ok wie kriege ich das jetzt gescheit rüber so in einer schönen bestseil ok publish dotnet
dotnet publish self contained publish single file true output bild ja das können wir schon
mal machen das ganz gut ok und jetzt jetzt brauche ich feifett bash bashkenner bild rsync
minus aha ist es glaube ich tunnel doch über die hetzer maschine ja mache ich ja quasi
jetzt gleich ich könnte ich könnte mir also was ich machen könnte ich könnte direkt auf
der hetzer kiste eigentlich entwickeln und per ssh fs mountain oder sowas aber ich kopiere
es jetzt rüber also rüber kopieren bild das bildverzeichnis nach root et kann man das
pullen ja klar aber das ist nach was für eine monitoring tool hast du dich umgeschaut was
für domains ja das kannst du dann auf github ziehen so bild rsync und jetzt gehen wir nach
zwar man ssh ist jetzt zwar nicht schön aber es müsste zweckmäßig funktionieren jetzt
gehen wir nach bild und starten dort dann domain champ domain ob das jetzt so funktioniert
wie ich mir das vorgestellt habe
ssh file ach ich bin ja auch blöd man das passiert mir immer wieder das passiert mir
immer wieder wir brauchen routen dann irgendwie sowas das sollte das eigentlich auf den server
rüber kopieren oder nicht warum nicht da ist es doch ich sollte minus v machen dass
ich eine ordentliche ordentliche ausgabe habe ja ok jetzt hat er auf den server rüber kopiert
und jetzt ssh root et da nach bild slash domain champ no such file achso ok alles klar jetzt
funktioniert es ok jetzt ist auf der hetzer kiste drüben und kann ausgeführt werden also
domain champ minus minus wie habe ich gesagt muss ich den campel aufrufen so ne warte mal
hier wo ist es api key keckel ip so jetzt warum ach ran habe ich vergessen domain champ
ran jetzt aber ja funktioniert also error domain cute chat punkt xxx alles gut ok jetzt
kann man das ausprobieren also jetzt müssen wir xml parsen jetzt wird es aber nicht was
der beste weg xml xml zu passen in dort net irgendwann hast du zu viele keckel projects
ich habe ein ein ernstes projekt auf github da wird es ein zweites was ich funktionsfähig
mache auch nicht xml zu Jason das ist tatsächlich eine ziemlich gute idee eigentlich ist eine
richtig gute idee xml zu Jason und dann Jason passen anstatt xml eigentlich die beste variante
hast du recht ok erste mal müssen wir diesen diesen request jetzt ordentlich machen also
wir kopieren uns mal kurz das hier raus das ist wenn wir das mal irgendwie base oder sowas
base url kann man das nämlich schon mal weg machen zack base base url so api key da kommt
hier der user rein api key kommt der key rein hier kommt noch mal der user rein weil es
irgendwelchen kunden doppelt sein muss und hier kommt die api rein domain get lists eigentlich
alles richtig so gucken wir mal ob das jetzt besser funktioniert die nahm dynamisch funktioniert
jawoll klappt immer noch ich sollte vielleicht mal das lieb raus machen das ist komplett unsinnig
ja gut funktioniert ja ok jetzt haben wir das dynamisch machen wir hier weg gut dann
haben wir unseren request das heißt als result kommt mal hier xml gleich result wir lesen
es ja schon als string ist ja alles gut ist ja schon ist ja schon ich meine wir können
es wahrscheinlich jetzt jetzt an den get from jason eisung ne das ok wir können das überschreiben
mit get get xml aber das brauchen wir nicht wir haben jetzt ja hier den text und den text
können wir in xml pappen hätte man eine frage kannst du mir die zeile erklären i durch ja
das ist ganz einfach lass mich raten du lernst kann in der schule was oder das bestimmt das
bestimmt bestimmt ist eine aufgabe aus der schule ja ok dann will ich jetzt mal ich kann
dir das erklären das ist tatsächlich relativ relativ einfach aber ich muss jetzt mal so
was denkst du denn dass es macht oder was hast du dir denn schon dazu überlegt bevor
ich dir erkläre was es macht wir können es die leute nicht zu einfach machen also ich
kann dir schon mal sagen eine sache das ding nennt sich modulo operator wenn von ich der
rest 3 oder 1 ist ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne aber aber es geht auf jeden fall in
die richtige richtung es geht auf jeden fall in die richtige richtung es ist nicht wenn
3 ist es ist mal gucken und die habe ich glaube microsoft kann es wahrscheinlich deutlich besser
erklärt sie schab modulo operator die performance operator arithmetic operations
so microsoft selbst also es geht um den rest das ist richtig genau steht ja auch da reminder rest
reminder operator compute still remain okay das natürlich after dividing genau das ist das ist
der rest nach dem teilen das ist das worum es bei der ganzen geschichte geht du teilst das durch
3 und dann guckst du was übrig bleibt also i sollte eine zahl sein sonst hast du probleme
aber wird er wahrscheinlich auch beim kompilieren merken du teilst die durch 3 und dann guckst du
das was übrig bleibt ob das der rest 1 ist so sieht es aus ja
kannst du das mal kurz zeigen was soll ich zeigen das ist das ist syntaktisch korrekt so
wie das da steht also das ist das ist richtig so wie es da steht da kann ich
jetzt nichts zeigen weil es würde wenn ich zeige genauso aussehen weil durch den debugger ballern
ne oder ok ok weil ihr seid chat weil ihr seid weil weil weil ihr das seid also
ich blende blende immer erst mal weg also was man jetzt machen kann ist value value ist keine
ahnung 4 zum beispiel so und jetzt guckst du if value durch drei nicht durch drei also ich
habe mich vertippt modulo 3 gleich gleich eins und wenn das der fall ist dann sagst du keckel so
und jetzt wird er hier jetzt wird er hier sagen expression ist always true na gut weil ich
hardcoded da eine 4 drinne stehen habe ich starte das ganze mal dort net run da wirst du sehen ja
funktioniert natürlich immer immer da nur 4 einzugeben ist natürlich relativ pepega weil
du weißt ja weißt ja was rauskommt wir können jetzt irgendwie sowas machen wie keine konsole
weiß gar nicht ob man das in dotnet so macht konsole reads read read line read key wie macht
man das überhaupt gescheit ja konsole read line machen wir jetzt konsole read line da müssen
wir das noch parsen was weiß ich input read line input da muss wahrscheinlich der input
muss wahrscheinlich auch drimmen oder ich muss den input noch drimmen dass irgendwie kein new line
mehr drinne ist also zumindest muss man sagen int pass wir können sagen int try pass input
aber was habe ich vergessen was war ich also aus result out war value das können wir machen
zum beispiel jetzt halt die frage ob sich das ganze parsen lässt wenn jetzt kann ich was
eingeben jetzt kann ich zum beispiel eingeben 4 und ich habe wahrscheinlich
ja doch funktioniert doch alles alles gut alles gut also jetzt gebe ich 4 ein ok dann sagen wir
irgendwie was weiß ich omega null keckel ist null weh was auch immer gebe ich 4 ein und das stimmt
jetzt gebe ich 5 ein und das stimmt nicht passt so eigentlich alles oder also
so weit so gut hast du keinen debugger der die werte zeigt doch kann ich machen wo ist
das neue das da nee ach nee quatsch der da neben invalid option elf language version 2
der debugger funktioniert noch nicht mal ist auch geil was invalid option elfer lang version
news lang version 2 list wie warum was was auch immer keine ahnung das ist das ist writer ich
weiß warum ist das kaputt ach kann das sein dass ich dass ich hier misst ich glaube ich weiß woran
es liegt wartet mal wie finde ich in dem menü was builds and tools jetzt downloads ja ich habe
irgendwie noch so ein ural dingsel das war nicht wir wollen user share net wollen wir haben safe
und jetzt aber aha jetzt funktioniert excellent vielleicht soll ich aber ein breakpoint setzen
ok breakpoint wunderbar value ist man das jetzt nicht angezeigt ich verwende den normalen sollte
man nicht normalerweise den welten wieder drüber havern können und man kriegt jetzt den value
angezeigt mit dem debugger oder verwende ich den verkehrt also visual studio debugger ist das so
wenn du deine wenn du wenn du hier drüber havers sollte doch der debugger eigentlich den wert
anzeigen oder nicht so wie gesagt mit dem studio debugger ist das so welche
er hängt noch in redline ja ja aber dafür muss da vorher value machen
aber muss ich doch man muss ich doch die variablen ans oder ist das was von der von
dem von dem neuen themen dass das irgendwie kaputt ist oder mich jetzt
breakpoint gesetzt er hat den breakpoint noch nicht erreicht wie doch klar da hängt er doch
sieht man doch hat er nicht jetzt ach so ich muss ja erst mal was eingeben alter ich ich
brauche ja noch ein input ja jetzt ok ok ich habe nichts gesagt sehr gut ach ja stimmt ich muss
ja erstmals eintippen jetzt sieht man das ok jetzt ist der wert 4 was ich ja dein problem
ist dass du 4 durch 3 teilst und denkst es wäre 1,333 was ja auch richtig ist aber nicht wenn du
mit ins bzw wenn du wenn du den rest haben willst wie hast du denn in der grundschule das ganze
gelernt du guckst ok du hast eine vier du guckst wie oft wie oft passt die drei in vier rein das
ist doch das was man in der grundschule lernt oder so nach dem motto ich soll rechnen vier
geteilt durch drei wie mache ich das ok ich gucke wie oft passt die drei in die vier rein
wie oft passt die drei in die vier rein chat einmal aber dann ist ja noch eins übrig also
hast du einen rest von eins die drei passt einmal rein und es bleibt ein rest von eins
und genau das machen modulo auch der teilt das durch der teilt das durch drei also guckt wie
oft passt das rein und dann den rest wieso bleibt ein rest von eins weil du vier durch
drei rechnest du guckst wie oft passt die drei in die vier ihr passt einmal rein und da bleibt
dann noch eins übrig was soll denn sonst übrig bleiben
bleibt ja nicht 0,3 übrig nee 0,3 übrig 1 1,3 also wenn du wenn du vier durch drei
rechnest da kommt ganz streng genommen wahrscheinlich 1,3 oder so was raus aber das geht ja nicht du
hast ja keine du hast ja keine kommas zur verfügung rechnest ja mit ins rechnest mit ganzen zahlen also
kannst du ja im prinzip nur rechnen das was vorm kommas steht weil du hast ja du kannst ja kein
comma darstellen zumal das egal ist wenn du das mit einem float machen willst dann sagt er
precision und so das wird natürlich jetzt blöd ich mach mal kurz den kann man den debugger
irgendwie wieder ausschalten da ist nichts 0,3 das ist der macht das gleiche was du in der
grundschule gemacht hast der rechnet vier in dem fall kannst du quasi sagen hier minus drei oder
so also du guckst wie oft passt die drei in die in die vier rein und was bleibt dann übrig
du könntest auch sagen du hast vier ok ok wir machen jetzt wir machen jetzt wirklich
du hast vier stücker kuchen und du hast drei leute so und jetzt du darfst aber du darfst
aber nicht irgendwie die stücke schneiden oder so du darfst aber nicht die stücke die stücke
zerschneiden das heißt dir bleibt nichts anderes nichts anderes übrig wie du hast vier stücker
kuchen und drei leute jeder kriegt ein stück kuchen und es bleibt eins übrig ich mein praktisch
gesehen würde ich wahrscheinlich zwei stück futtern aber es bleibt erst mal eins übrig
wenn du jetzt die stücke schneiden darfst dann bekommt jeder 1,3 stücke also jeder bekommt quasi
ein stück und noch ein drittel du darfst aber die stücke nicht zerschneiden also bleibt ein
rest von eins außer einer futter zwei ja und mit sieben mit sieben ist es auch so wenn man sagt
ups wenn man sagt sieben bei sieben stimmt das jetzt allerdings auch warum stimmt das bei sieben
naja wie oft das das kann mir jetzt watch watch one twitch two on three twitch erklären wie oft
passt die drei in sieben rein und wie viel rest bleibt 1 korrekt und deswegen klappt das hier also
wir machen mal eine ausgabe so keine ahnung wie viel rest ist eins und else nichts was heißt
nichts das wissen wir gar nicht rest könnte auch was anderes sein was anderes so jetzt gibst du
irgendwas ein so zum beispiel zum beispiel 6 was ist der rest was ist der was ist der rest von 6 modulo 3
null richtig also es ist der rest ist was anderes und was ist was ist drei man kann auch drei modulo
3 machen ist auch was anderes aber mit sieben ist es glaube ich ganz gut zu erklären du guckst
quasi immer ob der rest eins ist also egal was du machst du teilst das und guckst was bleibt
übrig und was du damit machen kannst ist du kannst zum beispiel gucken irgendwie ob zahlen ob die zahle
ob der zahle gerade ist kannst du zum beispiel ausprobieren guck mal angenommen du hast jetzt du
hast jetzt eine schleife was jetzt eine schleife von 1 bis 100 beziehungsweise von 0 bis 99 so und
jetzt willst du nur alle gerade zahlen ausgeben also was würdest du machen wie würdest du rauskriegen
ob eine zahl gerade ist hast du hast du irgendeine hast du irgendeine klor reiche idee wie könnt
du rauskriegen ob die zahl gerade ist heute ich weiß es gibt 30 milliarden varianten man könnte
npm install is even machen zum beispiel ja man könnte einfach auch binary die letzte stelle
angucken aber keine ahnung ok wie wäre es damit im modulo 2 zum beispiel ob der rest null ist du
teilst die zahl durch 2 und guckst ob es glatt aufgeht wenn du eine zahl durch 2 teilst und es
glatt aufgeht dann muss die zahl gerade sein was heißt wenn du das hier angibst also pass
sollte ich mal sollte ich mal wieder weg weg machen brauchen wir nicht mehr dann kriegst du nur alle
gerade zahlen guck wir machen es mal wir machen es mal bis bis 30 oder das ist nicht so lang
0 2 4 6 18 blub blub blub ich weiß wir wollen uns die reaction sogar noch angucken weil du jetzt
guckst zahl geteilt durch 2 bleibt ein rest wenn den rest bleibt dann machen wir nix und wenn kein
rest bleibt dann machen wir das was im if steht brauchst du link ne ne finde ich schon eigentlich
ist es doch ganz logisch oder kannst du vielleicht noch erklären wie ich das gleich gleich beachten
muss das muss jetzt im kontext erklären du meinst du meinst hier du meinst das hier streng
genommen sind das zwei ausdrücke die du miteinander vergleicht also ein if hat erst mal gar keine
ahnung von dem was da drinne steht wenn if versteht bloß ob der ausdruck true oder false ist das ist
natürlich logischerweise immer wird immer ausgeführt und das wird logischerweise nie ausgeführt wenn
ich jetzt ein ausdruck reinschreibe dann wird erst dieser ausdruck ausgewertet bzw. von links
von links nach rechts und ich zeige ich zeige sie im detail und das was hier rauskommt ist dann
entweder war oder falsch und dann reagiert das if drauf also kann zum beispiel auch so was machen
result erkennt man es wahrscheinlich besser man muss das nämlich gar nicht ins if reinschreiben
ist auch schon ok was jetzt gemacht wir können sogar noch mal wir können sogar noch mal klammern
dass das klarer wird wir können wir können sogar noch mal klammern also das erste was jetzt
passiert ist er führt das hier aus er teilt er teilt i durch 2 und er macht i modulo 2
hier kommt irgendwas raus also bei dieser operation kommt der rest raus ok machen wir
es mal anders war rest so int also hier kommt er hier kommt der rest raus wenn du i durch 2 teilt
und dann guckst du ist der rest null da kommt dann entweder raus ja oder nein und das if guckt dann
war es war es ja oder nein und war ja führt er das right line aus war nein
also also wenn man da probleme in der informatik umschulung hat sollst du wirklich ein bisschen
die basics angucken also ich mein jetzt jetzt wirklich alle einzelnen schritte da ich weiß
nicht was ich was ich noch mehr erklären sollte wichtig ist warum machst du die umschulung das
wird mich jetzt mal interessieren machst du die umschulung weil du dir denkst oder habe ich bock
drauf oder weil deine eltern gesagt haben du musst das machen oder so was weil es gibt leute die
haben wirklich überhaupt gar keinen hang zu sowas zu machen kann ja schon sein also beispielsweise
hatte ich das auch wenn du programmierer werden willst ja dann ok also wenn du von dir aus auf
die idee kommst ist natürlich was anderes also ich hatte es zum beispiel kaufmännischen sachen da
hatte ich überhaupt keinen bezug zu und habe auch kaum was gecheckt ja das stimmt ja wenn
du selbst programmierer werden willst da musst du kleine schritte einfach machen am anfang zum
beispiel sowas bis das bist du verstanden hast ich kann dir leider nicht allzu viel mehr dazu
erklären weil was soll ich noch zu sagen also so viel so viel schritte dazwischen gibt es jetzt
ja gar nicht mehr das wichtige ist bevor du dir sowas hier anguckst du musst verstehen was
eigentlich passiert also du musst wissen was der unterschied ist zwischen hier nem gleich und da
nem 2 gleich gleich als zeichen hintereinander also du musst dann quasi verstehen ok das hier
ist eine zuweisung das hier ist im vergleich also es hängt ein bisschen von der syntax der sprache
ab also bevor du irgendwelche algorithmen da drinnen baust musst du schon die syntax der
sprache verstehen also sprich was macht das hier was wie ist ein syntaktischen if aufgebaut später
später noch eine schleife weil wenn du schon probleme damit hast zu verstehen was der unterschied
ist zwischen hier 2 2 gleich als zeichen und da einem gleich dann scheitert schon an der syntax
da scheitert es nicht an dem verständnis des problemes sondern an der syntax also sprich du
weißt nicht wie du das was du machen willst so taktisch ausdrücken kannst genau und du hast
auch nicht viele operatoren die du brauchst genau mit dem einen weißt du was zu das ist das ist eine
zuweisung und das hier ist quasi ein vergleich du vergleichst ob die linke seite gleich der
rechten seite ist das geht bei der weine ich an der stelle du guckst ob die linke seite gleich
der rechten der rechten seite ist mittlerweile kann man in c-sharp sowas machen aber vergiss
es einfach mal ok wenn ein aufgaben platt hat dann lernt hat das in der schule und wenn
die linke seite gleich der rechten seite ist dann ist die aussage entweder wahr oder falsch und
das steht in result drin und das if guckt ob es wahr oder falsch ist und wenn es wahr ist wird
das ausgeführt und wenn nicht wird es halt übersprungen also ansonsten ich weiß halt
echt nicht was ich da groß dazu sagen soll es könnte natürlich auch sein dass es schlicht
nur greifend einfach ein bisschen viel ist es kann durchaus sein dass es einfach ein bisschen
viel ist je nachdem wie der lehrer das macht und ich weiß ja nicht wie viele stunden ihr da am tag
habt und sowas es könnte durchaus sein dass es am anfang einfach ein bisschen viel ist
und hier sind wir also muss ja auch keine gedanken machen dass du es nicht verstehen
kannst oder so also wir sind hier bei solchen eintracht auf einem niveau das kann wirklich jeder
verstehen vielleicht ist das eines der probleme dass du dich erst einen tag bevor du die arbeit
schreibst überhaupt mit dem inhalt beschäftigt also ich meine wenn du jetzt einfach die letzten
weiß ich wie lange die umschulung geht die letzten zwei monate nichts gecheckt hast und
auch nichts dagegen unternommen hast es zu checken und jetzt in einem tag das lernen willst was man
eigentlich hätte in zwei monaten lernen sollen das könnte natürlich auch das könnte natürlich
doch die wurzel die wurzel des problems sein ja du checkst nur nicht das mit den operatoren
ja gut also in dem fall das ist ja nur ein operator gewesen das war jetzt der modulo
operator es gibt ja noch mehr also du hast ja modulo ist beliebt modulo ist so ein lieblings
beispiel von programmierlehrern ehrlich gesagt modulo operator selbst verwendet man eigentlich
selten gibt paar sachen da braucht man aber meistens meistens eher nicht modulo ist ein
operator ganz genau gucken sogar zumindest in c-sharp sogar microsoft sagt dass modulo ein operator ist
es ist mir egal was der twitch chat sagt microsoft sagt in c-sharp ist das ein operator
c-sharp operator jetzt haben sie es auch noch auf haben es auch noch auf deutsch
alter herkel modulo auch da hat der herr gibt's ja wir haben noch die seite eben offen
operatoren rest da ist es doch hier kuck arithmetic operators also wenn microsoft es sagt kann es sich
schon darauf verlassen dass es zumindest in c-sharp ein operator ist
aber nicht hier das steht es ist der das ist der reste operator auf deutsch oder der rest der rest
meine operator wenn das microsoft sagt dann ist das für c-sharp so ganz ehrlich microsoft
entwickelt den kram es mag sicherlich sprachen geben da ist das nicht so es mag sicherlich
programmier sprachen geben da ist das nicht so da musst du dann irgendwie keine ahnung hier
irgendwie vier punkt mod keine ahnung drei oder so machen kann sein in c-sharp ist es ein operator
definitiv das steht in der offiziellen c-sharp spezifikation als ob in der offiziellen c-sharp
language reference als operator drin natürlich ist es sprachen abhängig wie das implementiert
ist man könnte das man könnte das natürlich auch als funktion machen ja man könnte auch
durchaus sagen vier modulo 3 oder so das gibt es gibt es auch ich habe eine kleine frage woher
weiß ich zum beispiel dass ich modulo 3 oder modulo 10 machen muss das kann man so pauschal
nicht sagen das hängt von dem problem ab was du lösen willst ob du das brauchst oder nicht
das genau das kommt auf die aufgabe an indem du verstehst was der typ der die aufgabe geschrieben
hat von dir wissen will du musst es verstehen was da war du kannst viele sachen übrigens auf
mehrere arten lösen also eine beliebte aufgabe ist zum beispiel sowas hier ja rauszufinden
welche zahlen welche zahlen gerade sind zwischen 0 und 29 dann würdest du genau so was machen also
alle zahlen ausgeben die gerade sind zwischen 0 und 29 dann weißt du ok da könnte man den modulo
operator für verwenden indem ich das checke ob ich es durch zwei teile und dann gucken ob
ein rest übrig bleibt man kann das auch anders machen also das ist immer eine frage das ja wie
man denn sich dem problem nähern will es gibt selten so eine lösung aber das dürfte wahrscheinlich
bei so einer frage was sein was der lehrer gerne sehen will du machst eine schleife machst modulo
wobei ganz ehrlich der lehrer will wahrscheinlich eher sowas sehen weil das die deutlich einfachere
schreibweise ist dann ist gut und wenn man es ganz eklig machen will lässt man sogar die klammern
noch weg weil man nicht bei ein einzeitigen also sowas sowas ist was wo sich der lehrer dann
wahrscheinlich denkt okay da hat verstanden was ich erzählen will oder was ich mit was ich
erzählt habe mein du hast jetzt hier natürlich mehrere ausdrücke drin du hast hier einmal also
man kann das man könnte es beispielsweise klammern dass man das man es besser sieht du hast einmal
das wird zuerst ausgewertet dann wird das ausgewertet das ist aber schon fertig und dann wird
das miteinander verglichen und dann kommt das if warum man kann man weiß die scharp eine code ohne
klassen schreiben weil microsoft das gut gefakt hat unter der haube kann ich jetzt sagen scharp lab
ich bin mir gar nicht sicher ob man das mittlerweile scharp lab sieht microsoft faked microsoft faked
das und zwar ok guck mal was da rauskommt bei siehst du es unter der haube ups moment moment moment
blödsinn ja ja using was ist das using system ist glaube ich reichte ja guck mal du kannst
es du kannst das direkt ohne klassen schreiben aber unter der haube wird das intern ganz normal in
der main methode gerappt also microsoft faked das einfach nur schön dass du das ohne klassen
und sachen ausführen könntest unter der unter der haube ist es ganz normal eine klasse die
programm heißt mit einer statischen main methode drin das ist einfach nur das einfach nur gut gefakt
ja übrigens nur mal so angemerkt weil wir das hier gerade haben es wäre auch möglich dass du
das auf binary ebene dir anguckst und schaust ob die letzte stelle eine null ist und so was
geht auch also man könnte das ganze auch mit irgendwelchen schift operators mal will man
aber nicht aus dem fall ist es mit modulo deutlich einfacher so ich glaube jetzt haben wir es oder
was mehr macht auf nüchternen magen was hey max ich habe eine ganz andere frage ich bin auch gerade
am abnehmen ich habe über weihnachten wieder ein bisschen zugenommen so irgendwie 3400 gram
muss ich muss jetzt wieder abnehmen minus 20 kilo also ich habe aktuell minus nicht ganz minus 20
so minus minus minus 17 18 habe ich gerade jetzt wollte ich fragen wie oft du dich wie unterschiedlich
meistens morgen paar mal die woche ja natürlich natürlich also ich hatte also wenn du die letzten
das minimale was ich hatte in letzter zeit war 91,4 und ich glaube das maximale war glaube ich
93,7 je nachdem ob ich mich ganz früh morgens hinstelle ob ich mal kacken gewesen bin ob ich
viel gefressen haben am tag davor also so ein kilo so ein zwei kilo schwankungen kommen schon vor
sternchen zeigen sollst du irgendeine pyramide in terminal ausgabe machen
ja könnte man auch machen
kannst du beide machen kannst du beide machen macht kein unterschied nicht in der ausbildung
kommt eher darauf an was du in der ausbildung machst das kann ja von betrieb zu betrieb
unterschiedlich sein und für was du dich interessierst oh 6 hat time siehst du das
hätte ich aus dem kopf nicht hingekriegt und mit eins und dann gucken okay ich glaube dir
jetzt einfach mal dass das dass das funktioniert okay ich würde sagen wir machen jetzt mal weiter
wir haben jetzt genug uns mit den basics beschäftigt und wirklich was gemacht haben wir ja noch nicht
glaube ich habe jetzt eine halbe stunde oder so also wo sind wir jetzt eigentlich stehen geblieben
wir wollen die gültigkeit von domains wie man xml passen kann sind wir glaube ich stehen geblieben
xml passen rsync rsync alles klar okay funktioniert also wie man xml passen kann wie macht man das in
dotnet xml ist so ein ding schon ewig noch mal richtig richtig seit einer ganzen weile nicht
mal verwendet also ich würde sagen wir könnten das noch mal umbrechen irgendwo an der stelle
warum nicht so wann geht das nicht mehr normalerweise kann man hier immer enter drücken
wahrscheinlich weil ich ein add drinne habe ja wunderbar ok also xml x document oder sowas
wie pas ich am besten also wie sieht denn die ausgabe aus cw result ich muss mir die ausgabe
noch mal angucken muss wir die ausgabe noch mal angucken also wir haben hier eine domain list also
wir haben eine api response die einfachste war ihre variante wäre tatsächlich xml umwandeln in
jason und dann jason aber das ist natürlich nicht so nicht so schön ok also api response erhors
warnings juckt mich juckt mich jetzt erstmal nicht hat drin haben wir dann eine command response
da drin haben wir dann eine domain get results list kein xml leute wir kommen nicht drumherum
wir müssen wir müssen xml machen ok x document jetzt abartig pass pass result xml gut und was
kann man damit jetzt machen root document alter hör mal doch auf mann hör mal doch auf gab es
nicht gab es nicht so eine selektor x pass select element ja genau so ging das doch irgendwie
was gegen xml spricht ja guck dir das mal an keine sau kannst lesen und das ist jetzt noch
ein kurzes xml das geht noch viel schlimmer es gibt teilweise fünf seiten xml du verstehst
nix gut xml ist auch nicht unbedingt für menschen lesbar gemacht außerdem ist xml unglaublich
groß also wie soll man sagen so der informationsgehalt zu rauschen ist in xml ziemlich schlecht also
xml hat informationen und 90 prozent bla bla bla es ist glücklicherweise auf dem absteigenden
ast mit xml gibt ja mittlerweile genug alternativen wenn es gut lesbar sein soll kannst du was
wie jammel oder tommel nehmen für web services und generellen austausch empfiehlt sich empfiehlt
sich jason wenn es schnell sein soll dann kannst du sowas wie protokoll buffers und
und grpc nehmen also wenn man nicht gerade irgendwelche alten windows microsoft services
hat die noch xml verwenden ist xml glücklicherweise ein bisschen auf dem absteigenden ast ja saub
ist noch schlimmer saub ist noch schlimmer web services mit saub das macht ja auch keiner
mehr ok x pass select element wie macht man das jetzt richtig x pass select element ich
habe keine ahnung x pass generator gibt es sowas dir der für ein x pass generator online
da ist was soll ich damit jetzt machen was was bin ich sehend
ich kopiere es ich kopiere es jetzt einfach mal rein ap response und was diese komische
xml brauche diese was diese komische komische seite das mal ok domain list results so so
kriege ich das also raus kann ich jetzt einfach so reinschreiben list schau mal mal und es
funktioniert nicht na geil wer hätte das gedacht wäre ja auch deutlich zu einfach c
scharp x pass select notes using x pass navigation ach gott xml common please was
ist ja schlimmer als die einzelnen not sich da raus zu holen was zu wissen wer soll das
lesen soll das verstehen die senden bk buchen wenn ich mich richtig erinnere dann ist ein
x pass der viele ergebnisse haben kann eine liste die ja ich brauche jetzt ein paar passes
dass das öffne es mal im browser den response und mach einen recht x pass ach ja haben die
so eine funktion ok ok das machen wir machen wir tatsächlich stimmt wir können irgendwelche
browser wir können irgendwelche browser tools dafür verwenden das probieren wir das probieren
jetzt wirklich mal aus einfach mal gucken ob man das ohne ohne eigenen hirn einsatz hinbekommen
keckel punkt xml so wunderbar chrome oder firefox firefox hat bessere entwicklungstools
keckel punkt xml ok das ist kein valid xml da kann man das schon mal sein lassen ok wir
machen das anders ich mein vom ansatz her vom ansatz her kann es ja nicht so kompliziert
sein also wir holen uns aus dem xml wir holen uns gibt es so was wie die sender ja die sendens
x name ok wir wollen das mal kurz gucken wir wollen was haben was domain get list result
heißt kann ich das einfach so machen run schau mal ok ok ok ok ok kannst du das nicht auf
ein objekt mapen doch da müsste ich aber allen ernstes eine klasse erstellen die das
alles enthält und zumindest zumindest die die sachen schachtel in anderem da bräuchte
ich dann da bräuchte ich dann ein abi response objekt da drinnen eine command response dann
da drin eine domain list mit einem domain list entry und sowas ich glaube nicht dass
der von xm also was wir machen können ist was tatsächlich ganz gut ist wie man kann
sich typen erzeugen lassen ich glaube ich glaube quick type kann das ob ob rider das
für xml kann keine ahnung also quick quick type kann das glaube ich ne systema quick
type kann auch bloß jason keine xml so schauen wir mal liste und jetzt ok for each mal gucken
ob das jetzt funktioniert for each x element in liste x element so mal gucken das sollte
ich jetzt ja jemand das sollte ich jetzt nur eins rausbekommen zack erkomme ich nichts
ok das ist schon mal falsch ok max max lernt dort net xml handling im stream x descendants
x name was zum teufel ist überhaupt ein x name ist das der der name vom element oder
was ist das convert xml so sie schab excellent feife da teile mal da wie was soll am ende
rauskommen ok das probiert das probiert einfach mal just for fun das probieren wir jetzt mal
aus ich weiß ja nicht mal was da rauskommen soll ok convert xml und wie füge ich da jetzt
was ein track und drop oder ane hier einfach reinschreiben ok habe ich es denn zack ok
convert aha xml hutsch das hört ja gar nicht mehr auf man alter 113 zeilen ne ne ne ne
ok ich könnte natürlich nur die sachen rausholen die mich interessieren also sprich aber trotzdem
hier so das interessiert mich das interessiert mich das interessiert mich das interessiert
mich nicht ja das könnte ich das könnte ich löscht aber trotzdem nee ach page ich
muss ich vielleicht auch abfackeln wenn es mehrere seiten gibt api response warum alles
nicht für mich interessiert bloß die command response ja das das könnte ich das könnte
ich wahrscheinlich wirklich nehmen also das das wäre aber das widerspricht das widerspricht
mir trotzdem wir können chat gpt fragen tatsächlich ja ich bin ja gar nicht eingeloggt ok ich
bin aber leider ich bin zu dumm xml zu verwenden was ist jetzt in dieser liste überhaupt drinne
wenn man das ausführt ok was ist in der liste drinnen monka es alles klar so error command
response ok ok das ist nur die erste das ist nur die erste ebene quasi was ist der
unterschied zwischen ich brauche die sendet notes brauche ich gibt es irgendwie sowas
wie xml root ja so was suche ich so was so was suche ich gerade so und jetzt mal was
select oder wer wer element woher weiß ich jetzt name gibt es etwas wie name fack woher
weiß ich wieder kam jetzt heißt parent node post ist ekle document parent was kommt da
jetzt raus mann nix ah poc poc extrem nice ok also alles klar domain result domain ja
genau und ich will was ist denn wie nennt man das denn hier wer ich will alles haben
was domain heißt wo der note der note type oder type note type nee wie nennt man das
hier vorne das ist ein ich hätte jetzt gedacht es ist der name aber es ist anscheinend nicht
der name ist es es ist der scheiße zu muss ja irgendwie sowas jetzt hier machen null
nee mensch was ok base base ist nicht write write document parent note type ok note type
comment attribute ah moment das ist ah das muss doch nicht mal nen element sein ich will
gucken ob es nen element ist vielleicht doch elements ok vielleicht will ich auch einfach
elements haben das kann auch sein achtung five hat time sowas in der art ja sowas suche
ich genau sowas in der richtung ok so elements wer element nee hat es jetzt nen name ah das
hat nen name ok jetzt schauen wir mal ob da jetzt was sinnvolles bei rauskommt ich habe
keine ahnung was ich hier mache ok was denn das schon wieder xml parsen man ok elements
ist schon mal warum gibt es bei elements vor allem nur api response also die standard notes
klingt doch eigentlich schon irgendwie sinnvoll ich glaube das war gar nicht verkehrt x pars
select elements ja das ist ja das ist ja das element was wir hier haben und jetzt und jetzt
noch mal hier elements vielleicht vielleicht vielleicht ihr habt recht vielleicht vielleicht
so gut was hat er hier ist nix null null gibt es bei uns nicht einfach outdated null ist
nicht existent null gibt es nicht ah ja command response nee das will ich nicht ich will
domain ich command response ist elements nicht eine liste nein elements ist ja so eine art
liste warum das warum das ne funktion ist musste microsoft fragen ich will sowas wie
alle alle unter alle elemente unten drunter haben ich glaube da ist die standard notes
tatsächlich enzastos enzelf die sendens enzelf das will ich haben vermute ich jetzt einfach
mal die sendens also alles was runterkommt und es selbst domain ja ja ja genau das will
ich haben also muss man erstmal wirklich hut machen ja ja die sendens enzelf komm das ist
das ist ich ich definiere jetzt es ist nicht null ok und jetzt will ich sagen name gleich
gleich domain where where gleich gleich domain
warum kommt jetzt nichts raus heißt es nicht domain count count ist wirklich keck alu timer
null ok anscheinend ist das ist alter das ist doch eindeutig name war doch domain oder
nicht alle ich raste aus ist ein scheiß man nee was ist der name was ist das schon ist
es irgendwie namespace shit oder was was ist das für ein müll ok welcher part davon
ist einfach nur element name element name mein name ist ja anscheinend schon mal richtig
note type ist empty has angeboten value was ist was ist denn das was kommt bei value raus
das ist das ist schon mal nicht verkehrt aber also was sie nicht checken was ist das
was ist das für ein xx name a local name local name vielleicht local name common pro
jetzt local name ah ok domain so jetzt muss es aber funktionieren
aha wir haben es und dann haben wir jetzt auch eine liste davon domain id bla bla bla
name cute chat ja wunderbar ok wir haben eine liste wir haben endlich eine liste mit
diesem ganzen shit excellent ganz toll so jetzt haben wir eine liste mit allen domains wir
checken mal ob das prinzipiell auch mit mehr domains funktioniert wir müssen noch eine
zweite domain wer hat eine gute idee was brauchen wir noch wir brauchen noch eine domain was
nehmen wir denn ok boomer punkt de keckel punkt bis ok boomer punkt ai das brauche
ich ja wie kann man ich kann man nicht kaufen ok boomer x y z alles klar was habe ich da
alles was habe ich da alles schon drin ach so ok boomer punkt ai habe ich schon check
123 euro easy übrigens ich kaufe nicht wirklich was das ist alles sandbox api die domains
werden noch nicht mal geordert ich mein guck ping cute chat punkt xxx gibt's net forever
auto renew forever ja konfirm pay jawoll erst mal virtuelle nicht fahrende dollars ausgegeben
und irgendwann sollte es noch schaffen subscriber punkt jetzt mit prime punkt ne subscriber
punkt jetzt punkt mit punkt prime ja das so das ist der domain die brauchen wir ok so
jetzt sollte ich nämlich zwei ausgaben bekommen achtung ja domain id und domain ja so ist
und und ok boomer punkt ai das funktioniert ich bin begeistert ich bin begeistert gut
jetzt brauchen wir tatsächlich ein extra objekt für also wir haben domain domain check result
domain check result beinhaltet den domain name und expires add gibt es noch irgendwelche
anderen sinnvollen sachen wahrscheinlich nach created ist jetzt nicht so spannend das
hat ja schlichte das hat ja nicht jeder anbieter muss ja was jeder anbieter hat nö eigentlich
nicht es interessiert es interessiert eigentlich ja es interessiert wirklich nur expires und
der name sonst sonst nix so also sprich ach kann man jetzt hier mit array mit nein natürlich
nicht das wäre auch zu einfach wahrscheinlich muss sowas wie get attribute oder sowas attribute
ja das das gucken wir jetzt das gucken wir jetzt wie man das rauskriegt also name gibt
das moment mal github sich wollen das wollen wir gucken github c sharp xml gibt es da gibt
es da was neues xml topics topics xml c sharp damit aber jetzt sich keiner auseinander was
ist der unterschied zwischen records und klassen records sind ohne dass du strug da voran gibt
sind klassen records sind klassen allerdings ist bei records ein paar sachen default mäßig
schon vorgegeben die du bei klassen selber machen müsstest also records sind klassen
deswegen ist der default ja auch record class und nicht record strug also records sind ohne
dass du was da hinten angibt sind klassen allerdings sind bei records schon equals und
get hashcode und equals operator und sowas überschrieben also du hast mit einem record
quasi eine klasse die sich eher wie ein struct verhält du kannst zum beispiel du hast hier
eine public class oder public record keckel das ist das gleiche wie public record class
sagt er auch hier also das geht du kannst entweder struct oder class aber struct ist
eigentlich selten also das ist eigentlich die komplette ausgeschriebene schreibweise
ja record class das ist auch der default also wenn du class weglässt ist es ist der record
quasi nur eine klasse und kein struct das liegt daran records gab es schon vorher bevor
es records structs gab deswegen hat man das hier optional gehabt also das ist die das
ist quasi die ausgeschriebene schreibweise davon und wenn du jetzt zum beispiel hier
einen felt drinne hast aber public war mal public int blub gleich null ob ich es so richtig
schreiben könnte gut wir machen jetzt mal das record weg chat jetzt seid ihr wieder
gefragt ich muss mal kurz mal ganz in krempel hier aus kommentieren durch zeug aus weil
ich nicht ausführen will jetzt ist der jetzter chat wieder gefragt also wir machen jetzt
war ja value 1 gleich new keckel und muss ich übrigens umgedreht schreiben und wir
machen value 2 auch new keckel und jetzt ist die frage was kommt da raus wenn ich jetzt
gucke value 1 gleich value 2 was kommt da jetzt raus true oder false run dot net run
da kommt falls raus richtig xml sabotiert uns grad noch da kommt falls raus warum kommt
da falls raus zeige ich euch gleich jetzt machen wir aber den record raus und was kommt
jetzt raus gut ich kann es mir sparen jetzt kommt da true bei raus warum und warum ist
das so genau nicht record klar es war es warum ist das so weil wenn du record schreibst
schon einige sachen überschrieben werden zum beispiel wird get hashcode und equals überschrieben
so dass nicht mehr die referenz verglichen wird sondern die werte miteinander verglichen
werden der unterschied ist oder besser gesagt vielleicht jetzt noch mal zur erklärung weil
ich glaube das fällt auch vielen die die neue sind gerade was was auch sie scharf angeht
ein bisschen schwer warum sind diese zwei sachen nicht gleich liegt daran wurde gerade interrupted
das liegt daran weil was hier verglichen wird ist nicht etwa der inhalt sondern ob
es wirklich die gleiche instanz ist also quasi ungefähr das was da und gerade im chat schreibt
ist es wirklich die gleiche speicher adresse trifft es nicht so ganz also ist es wirklich
die gleiche instanz kann man sich so ein bisschen vorstellen wie in c wenn man irgendwie zwei
pointer miteinander vergleicht ob es unterschiedliche speicher adresse ist also das ist die referenz
die hier überprüft wird also ist das wirklich die gleiche instanz ist es nicht hier legen
wir eine instanz an und hier legen wir eine instanz an und dementsprechend ist natürlich
wenn ich die referenz überprüfe dass was unterschiedlich ist wenn ich jetzt so machen
würde dann wäre das true weil jetzt ist es jetzt ist in wahl eins und wahl zwei jeweils
die referenz hiervon weil ich habe sie danach hat zugewiesen wenn ich da jetzt rekord draus
mache dann ist es true weil er da nicht mehr die referenz vergleicht sondern den inhalt
so was ähnliches gab es früher schon ich konnte auch so was wie struct machen da hat
er es auch gemacht allerdings hatte das ein paar andere probleme also das ist eigentlich
der unterschied rekord überschreibt schon standardmäßig ein paar metoden so dass die
werte miteinander verglichen werden standardmäßig werden bei klassen eben die referenz miteinander
verglichen rekord haben übrigens auch ein paar andere coole sachen wenn wir gerade dabei
sind was man eigentlich sehr selten verwendet aber es ganz ganz gut man kann rekord zum
beispiel bei man das nicht nur ja später da später es ist jetzt die sache diese betrifft
nicht nicht nur rekord aber es gibt ein paar nette syntaktische spielereien mittlerweile
zum beispiel wenn du wenn du wenn du jetzt was ich erste int und dann hast du hier irgendeine
zahl ja prime prime sub zum beispiel und du möchtest jetzt wenn das hier angelegt wird
dass das hier gesetzt werden muss früher hättest du das so gemacht du hättest den
constructor eingefügt hättest gesagt es muss prime sub gesetzt sein und dann hättest
du hier innen drinnen prime sub dann zugewiesen so dann musst du jetzt hier immer eine zahl
eingeben sonst kannst du das ganze nicht anlegen das war manchmal ein bisschen umständlich
deswegen gibt es jetzt was neues und zwar man kann jetzt schreiben in it das ist ein
teil davon ist ein teil davon dann kann ich während ich das anlege einmalig was zuweisen
wenn ich jetzt danach versuche wieder was zuzuweisen zuzuweisen dann geht das nicht
weil er mir sagt hey das ist in it only also das geht nur beim anlegen kann ich das zuweisen
und wenn ich jetzt allerdings mit dieser synthax will dass was zugewiesen werden muss dann
kann ich jetzt und das geht erst an der letzten c sharp version kann ich auch required davor
schreiben und jetzt sieht man ok der hier den kann ich nicht anlegen warum weil es
required ist dass ich prime sub angebe das gibt es jetzt ganz neu erst seit ein paar
monaten seit c sharp 11 ist manchmal ganz praktisch ist es ist es ist es nicht so als
würde man es wahnsinnig oft brauchen danach kannst du es nicht mehr setzen nein es ist
in it das heißt du kannst es nur initial setzen und es ist required das heißt es ist
beim anlegen in dat gut kann sein dass dat ein bisschen funktionaler ist oder so dat
habe ich noch nicht groß was gemacht wir haben im unternehmen vb.net programme du solltest
lieber c sharp lernen vb.net ist ein dat du kannst ja deine dotnet programme deine vb
programme theoretisch mit c sharp zumindest nicht wirklich erweitern aber du kannst die
gleichen sachen die gleichen libraries und so verwenden vielleicht gibt es auch einen
converter vb.net nach c sharp was wollte ich jetzt noch zeigen ja also das geht nicht
das ist required du kannst jetzt zum beispiel sagen set anstatt in it wenn du sagst set
dann kannst du im nachhinein noch was zuweisen aber die kombination aus in it und required
lässt nur initial einmal zu und das ist pflicht wenn du jetzt also das ist auch einer der
gründe warum records überhaupt erschaffen wurden wenn du denen wenn du das jetzt ändern
möchtest also wenn du wir machen wir dem amt das zwei weg wenn du sagen willst hey ich
hätte jetzt allerdings gerne das gleiche value eins nur dass in prime sub was anderes drin
steht dann müsstest du schreiben value eins wie geht das jetzt mit prime sub gleich zwei
das kannst du machen was hat er für schmerzen ich blödsinnig dann würde er quasi alles
übernehmen von value eins nur das hier neu setzen und daraus ein neues objekt erstellen
damit das damit man das richtig zeigen kann müsste ich müsste ich auch noch einen zweiten
noch ein zweites anlegen haben wir in it in it und jetzt muss ich das hier natürlich angeben
keqw ist zwei oder ist 99 und jetzt kann ich quasi sagen ich möchte das was in value eins
drinne steht behalten allerdings will ich prime sub neu setzen und daraus dann ein neues
keckel objekt erzeugen also das hier sind jetzt nicht mehr die gleichen du kannst das
aber nach dem anlegen nicht wieder ändern das heißt wenn du das irgendwo speichert
kannst du dir sicher sein nachdem du es gespeichert hast wird niemand irgendjemand wieder außer
per reflection aber dann ist hier eh nicht mehr zu helfen an diesem objekt wieder was
ändern also das ist zum beispiel ganz gut sagen wir mal für logs oder so was ein log
eintrag mit einem time stamp oder so ok da willst du nichts mehr dran ändern und gut
ist aber du möchtest vielleicht daraus was neues erzeugen mit einem neuen time stamp
aber der rest soll gleich bleiben dann kannst du diese syntax hier nehmen das sind alles
features die sind in erst in den letzten paar c sharp versionen dazugekommen seitdem sie
angefangen haben die sprache ein bisschen funktionaler zu machen du hast jetzt ja auch relativ komplexes
pattern matching und sowas drin ich finde sie haben es an manchen stellen ein bisschen
übertrieben gerade das microsoft so viele sachen eingebaut hat die sie anscheinend nur
selbst brauchen und sonst niemand auf der welt aber ich finde es gut ich finde es gut dass
ich es habe auch nach 20 jahren oder so immer noch relativ relativ schnell entwickelt und
die meisten sachen sind ja auch gute neuerungen
das braucht man selten aber wenn man es braucht ist gut dass es das gibt so ich mache mal
weiter mit unserem xml kram das sollten wir heute zumindest noch hinkriegen r sync wo
sind wir stehen geblieben stehen geblieben xml
alles klar hier so name was wollte ich jetzt machen ich wollte mir rausholen expire
du weißt nicht warum man keine inny dateien mehr nimmt man kann inny dateien nehmen es
ist also warum man keine inny dateien mehr nimmt das ist eher so eine frage von was gerade
angesagt ist aktuell ist jammel angesagt jammel oder blazingly fast written in rust tommel
tommel ist auch ganz beliebt aber jammel ist eigentlich beliebt kannst auch inny dateien
nehmen ja xml ist ist xml für wpf quasi aber inny kann man kann man benutzen es hat sich
so mal jammel hat sich die letzten jahre über halt etabliert so ein bisschen als standard
ohne ohne jetzt wirklich so verpflichtend zu sein ja du kannst also ich also hier das
programm das frisst eine jason config oder eine jammel config und ich habe mir das leben
total einfach gemacht passt mal auf ich habe
ich gucke ob es dateien gibt die jammel jimmel oder jason heißen und dann öffne ich die
in einem jammel parser weil jedes jason ist auch gültiges jammel und wandel die nach
jason um und dann bearbeite ich sie mit jason punkt nett das ist zwar doppelt gemoppelt
als fack aber es funktioniert so muss ich mich nicht darum kümmern ob es jammel oder
jason ist es geht einfach wobei man nicht nicht unbedingt jedes jammel nach jason konvertieren
kann wenn man referenzen benutzt und so dann geht das nicht aber wer macht so was in der
config datei so also was muss ich mir denn jetzt hier rausholen it just works ja ich
muss name name muss ich rausholen und expires muss ich rausholen und das dato müssen wir
irgendwie ordentlich pasen gleich ok also holen wir uns mal raus ne so ging nicht gell attribute
attribute ich will attribute name haben mal schnell schauen ob das funktioniert
ja warum steht als name gleich muss ich jetzt noch sagen value oder das ist so cringe diese
handhabung man es meckert ihr mich wahrscheinlich an wegen könnte null sein ok also das ist
der name ok name ist natürlich blödsinn domain ist das hier domain war gleich so das ist
der name sagt er mir jo achtung achtung warum könnte das eigentlich null sein das das
könnte nicht nur das könnte null sein es könnte ja das attribute nicht geben ja ok
das das kann doch kann tatsächlich sein so und dann haben wir noch expires expires ok
also expires value ok gut jetzt haben wir die zwei sachen geben wir das mal aus und geben
wir mal hier expires aus da sollte ich jetzt rauskriegen cute chat und das datum und ok
boomer punkt ai und das datum genau passt wunderbar sehr schön was muss ich das irgendwie
pasen das ist amidatums format oder ne das ist doch doch doch das ist monat das ist monat
tag ja also müssen wir quasi irgendwie so was haben wir hier dates oder unix ne war
mal unix datetime konverter was zum leiden hier war das datetime off offset es zum glück
keine urzeit dabei deswegen hatte er nicht normalerweise hier an dem moment expires expires
kann ich jetzt format angeht kann man hier ne das geht so nicht also muss ich datetime
moment wie hat man das jetzt noch expires
moment war das pass format das war nicht einfach nur pass oder wie kann man auch mal das format
ich ich bilde ich dachte das ging so ich habe datetime pass format pass pass exakt war es
aber das sollst du ja mal aus dem kopf wissen so und jetzt kannst du hier diesen krempel
an ja doch das hatte doch normalerweise autocomplete dafür ich nicht so streng ich will pass exakt
er ist wieder so behilfreich
provider ja genau
das will ich genau das will ich aber das hat der hatte doch weiter normalerweise autocomplete
für und was hat er für schmerzen warum geht das nicht moment expires ist doch ein string
was hat er für schmerzen cannot resolve warum nicht ein format provider das ging doch das
ging doch das ging doch das ging doch einfacher was muss denn muss er jetzt die die ach so
culture invariant ok kann man machen da nimmt er ja jetzt jetzt hat er autocomplete für
ja geil vorher nicht man muss erst alles auswählen jetzt ihr wollt doch sagen dass ich wusste
doch dass der kram autocomplete für hat genau short date das will ich haben ich habe ich
die ganze zeit was will das denn von mir man ok cw soll das heute ist was sinnvolles bei
rauskommen bäm jawoll ja zwölf uhr keck mir egal zwölf uhr schreibt zwölf uhr rein
soll mir recht sein so und jetzt muss ich mal gucken datetime datetime offset das exakt
und da muss man wahrscheinlich den gleichen müll angeben oder ja so ja und warum ich
datetime offset nehme ist ganz einfach weil ich to you next time milliseconds haben will
und das gibt es nur das gibt es nur in datetime offset zeit so sind mir wurscht ok jetzt habe
ich das ganze in you next time milliseconden das ist das was ich auch am ende brauche oder
brauche ich überhaupt was nee ich ach ich will es hier direkt als datetime haben datetime
offset haben ich bin mir aus dem kopf gar nicht mehr so so sicher ich glaube datetime
offset ist das hat irgendwas irgendwas mit zeitzonen zu tun steht da irgendwas dabei
represent point in time typically expressed as a date and relative to coordinate universals
keine ahnung was der unterschied ist geht das denn nach 2000 ja das ist ein können wir
gucken das ist ein int ein long ja das geht das geht ok datetime offset pass exakt so
wunderbar ganz toll also das brauchen wir das brauchen wir nicht gut und jetzt müssen
wir irgendwas zurückgeben also legen wir auch mal eine liste an result gleich new lists
domain check result ah nee result gibt es doppelt excellent result gibt es doppelt
und da gibt es jetzt result result add new domain check result domain haben wir name
und expires add haben wir auch accept ja wir machen wir geben überhaupt nichts zurück
also sollte sollte namen nicht gesetzt sein können wir noch können wir noch hier machen
if sehr schön was will er mir vorschlagen konverto link expression obviously viel besser
lesbar alles klar ja also ich finde ich finde wir sollten wir sollten es besser so schreiben
oder was mein ihr ich glaube das ist deutlich besser lesbar als das andere ich glaube manchmal
manchmal ist eine schleife gar nicht so verkehrt gut jetzt können wir sagen return result tja
das sollte jetzt eigentlich funktionieren und jetzt kriegen wir hier unten run enable
bla bla bla war result result for each check result so wir können jetzt auch eine sache
machen die ganz ganz nützlich ist eine ist schon ein record ok so schauen wir mal ob
jetzt ordentlichen ordentlichen output bekommen wunderbar funktioniert und schon haben wir
unseren ersten domain check eingebaut den wir benutzen können also sprich man kann es
jetzt aufrufen mit minus namcheap ap user ap key namcheap client ip das ist schick das
ist schick ach ja ich habe den prometors exporter ja wieder rausgeschmissen das sollte ich das
bauen wir jetzt das bauen wir jetzt mal wieder ein ich war jetzt blöd warte mal so zum glück
habe ich mir das gespeichert domain domain champ old weil ich weiß immer nicht wie man
das wie man diese komische library hier verwendet program wo habe ich wo habe ich hier mein prometors
prometors exporter wo ist er hier da war hier da oben das da brauche ich set numbers die
set or wim set nam no set acht set no nam set ausrufe zeichnen aha
so kann man kann sie den leuten nicht so einfach machen gelb
ok blabla blabla port 9000 9000 910
ok und jetzt setzen wir das ganze
ich habe das parallele ausführen und so hier gar nicht drinnen was wir letztens noch gemacht
haben enable checks ich sollte jetzt noch das mal in einer endlos schleife ausführen
weil das ist zwar nicht asynchron aber das macht jetzt zum aus macht jetzt zum ausprobieren nix
so und wir setzen jetzt den with labels muss ich noch mal abgucken label so so macht man das
ja wim zahlen nummern ist das über den con shop machen das nee das ist ein prometors exporter der
läuft einfach die ganze zeit und exportiert das über den web server wissen wir gleich sehen so
check result expires ad jetzt brauche ich das haben wir doch schon hier richtig check result
expires ad 2 unix time milliseconds domain alles richtig trage zeichen ach so moment fuck ich will
doch jetzt bestimmt nicht ok jetzt muss ich mich auf mein das läuft ja in der cloud gerade das
ding und ich bei mir lokal dann muss ich wohl oder übel ja gut ich kann es einfach überall
aufmachen was ist die ip root root jetzt wollt ihr könnt jetzt auf mein not exporter gleich draufgehen
der sink schauen wir mal ob das funktioniert vermisst was jetzt ich bin in name cheap old
in domain champ alt ich pepega noch mal hey da sind wir
oh wartet mal was jetzt ich händel mein exit event nicht kann das sein dass es jetzt weiter
weiter läuft im hintergrund das läuft weiter okay ich muss mal gut kill all domain champ wie
geht alter hier alles nicht drauf fast nicht wie heißt das mein gott db an kill all wie heißt das
package abt i can find was muss ich installieren ps misc obviously ps misc cringe wenn ich weiß
dass man ps misc installieren muss dafür ok so alles klar ja ich bin bescheuert ich habe
hier nirgends von ins lieb drinnen der der der flitzt hier gerade in der endlosschleife und hört
nicht mehr auf und außerdem muss ich nicht true machen sondern token ist cancellation requested
nope und hier unten machen wir mal wenigstens a weight delay task delay lassen wir mal mindestens
mal über zehn sekunden alter ich hoffe die haben ich jetzt nicht blacklisted weil ich so
viele anfragen geschickt habe kann durchaus sein leute kann durchaus sein ohne scheiß wäre
durchaus möglich ich habe ja quasi im sekunden takt oder willi sekunden takt gerade abgefragt
ok der request dauert ja auch kurz ich glaube ganz schlimm ist nicht guck mal mal also blablabla
hier so dass da auch tatsächlich komisch reza ist ja token cancellation token run hat auch
das cancellation token ok ok das war überlegen ist das jetzt alles richtig so wir machen noch
mal ein output wir machen noch mal ein output irgendwie so dass ich weiß dass es läuft ja
zehn sekunden später sollte wieder also leute ihr könnt jetzt ihr könnt jetzt alle mein
nord export am internet aufmachen beide das ist publik im internet gerade verfügbar ok
funktioniert funktioniert alles klar man könnte man könnte die expire time noch berecht berechnen
so und jetzt probieren wir mal was aus jetzt probieren wir mal was aus es sollte jetzt wenn
ich eine neue domain kaufe automatisch eine ich brauche keine proxy chain und kein user
agent rotation ich will den ja gar nicht alle sekunde abfragen ich will ja gar nicht geplack
listed werden das ist schon ok ich frage man realistisch betrachtet fragt man das dann alle
viertel stunde oder so ab so aber jetzt nochmal zum ausprobieren also es sollte wenn ich jetzt
eine neue domain kaufe also fake fake kaufe sollte die automatisch probieren mal ich schiebe das mal
hier rüber hier haben wir den hier haben wir den exporter output ja gibt es ein autorefresh
plugin für chrome aber chrome auto refresh ich will das ist automatisch easy easy autorefresh
ne f5 ist f5 ist kacke das sieht nach scam aus die software die sieht das sieht richtig
nach beschiss aus das verwende ich kann man kann man haben die entwickler tools sowas
chrome deftools autorefresh go to website hier open was set interval set interval
funktioniert nicht weil ich mit refresh die komplette seite reload ist wieder weg
developer tools konz ja ja ist das ist lustig dass sowas in den developer tools nicht gibt
egal wie wir klicken wir klicken jetzt einfach von hand wir fragen das jetzt von
hand oder noch besser leute kommen warum sollten wir überhaupt einen browser verwenden
siehst du mal wir sind richtige kacknubs wir hätten einfach karl dafür ja weil weil
schuhe du dann sleep eins dann jawoll so muss das sein und vorher und vorher machen wir noch
clear jetzt jetzt kann man jetzt keine life zugucken watch watch karl nein könnte man auch
machen was soll deutlich sinnvoller aber so geht es auch soll es können zugucken jetzt
kaufen wir mal eine neue domain jetzt haben wir mal eine neue domain wir brauchen noch
was wir brauchen noch was chat high iq viewers only punkt tv was kostet diese domain 12
euro im jahr easy ist gekauft stimmt das zeitformat doch das zeitformat ist richtig das ist milli
millisekunden seit 1970 unix timestamp haben wir aktuell haben wir moment also stimmt doch
nächstes jahr läuft es ab ist richtig ist richtig was läuft nächstes jahr ab über nächstes
jahr die andere so über nächstes jahr high iq viewers only check out den dns leute das
geht aber am sinn vorbei dahinter dünn dns ok konfirm oder besser
ok wir payen und jetzt sollte eigentlich bald bei einer neuen domain automatisch hier rechts
auftauchen alles funktioniert die verbleibende zeit public use nein da ist es beim leute aufgetaucht
high iq viewers only punkt tv ist automatisch refreshed alle zehn sekunden im hintergrund
über die api wobei zehn sekunden halt deutlich zu zu viel ist deutlich zu viel ja das backt
ich weiß auch woran das liegt dass der nicht automatisch über ssh sich beendet ich glaube
das liegt daran weil ich das nicht als typewriter starte ja heißt so ich glaube minus t muss
man machen und dann sendet er so sachen wie control c und somit wenn ich richtig fliege
zack mal control c jetzt läuft auch nicht mehr das heißt wirklich typewriter weil das aus
zeiten kommt wo leute noch schreibmaschinen verwendet haben ok es funktioniert neue domain
neue domain gekauft und also fake fake gekauft und der exporter funst das ist sehr nice das
gefällt mir wäre es nicht besser für public use also wie gesagt sind ich für public use
für mein monitoring system und daran würde ich jetzt zum beispiel den prometor hängen
er das einsammelt und da mache ich im kafana eine auswertung man könnte eventuell noch
man könnte noch sowas machen wie days left oder sowas oder ja was könnte man da noch
alles ausrechnen lassen oder seconds bis es abläuft willst du noch einen ssl check bauen
nö ssl check gibt es ja schon jede menge sachen für da gibt es gibt es ja schon jede
menge sachen für wirklich gucken ob die domain ausläuft ja alarm an email senden ist überhaupt
kein problem nimmste alert manager oder irgendwas anderes das muss da nicht eingebaut werden
das macht es ist ja nur ein exporter für die daten das den rest macht dann was anderes
preisschwankung ich will ich bin mir geht es einfach darum dass man weiß wann der kram
abläuft so einmal man könnte man könnte jetzt tatsächlich noch sowas machen wie also
quasi sowas wie seconds left oder sowas machen wir mal probieren mal hier require seconds
left und was könnte man machen dann seconds left ist dann okay müssen wir mal ausrechnen
left das ist quasi date time offset now nee das ist das das hier date minus left seconds
left in total seconds was ist jetzt für ein problem das muss kein int sondern ein double
sein weil es viele sekunden sein können jetzt kriegen wir zwar noch die sekunden übrig
bleiben da könnte man jetzt noch einen zusatz eintrag machen genau dass wir jetzt sagen
nicht wo schreibe ich das am besten rein das müsste ich da müsste ich noch ein anderes
label machen dann muss hier ein anderes label machen wir haben jetzt quasi domain das heißt
ich bräuchte quasi expire ad sowas und dann bräuchte ich glaube domain ist eher so mit
oder domain haben wir sowas seconds left dann zum beispiel noch machen und labels wie spreche
moment moment ich bin ja auch blöde warte mal warte mal warte mal wie spricht man das
jetzt an nee nee domain ist domain und jetzt jetzt blick ich wieder nicht durch wie macht
man jetzt multiple mehrere labels ich hasse dieses diese library alle ich weiß immer
nicht wie ich brauche ich brauche tatsächlich zwei oder ich brauche ich brauche zwei sachen
ich glaube so ist so ist richtig seconds left schau mal mal jetzt funktioniert ja funktioniert
also wir haben jetzt seconds left ja ok das sollte man vielleicht mal die also die die
milli nanosekunde genau muss ja nur wirklich nicht sein da schneiden wir einfach ab hinten
aber es funktioniert tatsächlich ganz gut was ist anstatt weil tauchen not oder weil
not tauchen ist kannst denn solltest du lieber weil zu tauchen was moment tauchen throw if
cancellation requested weil du nicht wissen kannst ob die methode unterbrochen worden
ist oder completed ist macht das ein unterschied danach ist eh vorbei also ich meine ich verstehe
dass es ein unterschied ist aber ich meine dann passiert ja nichts mehr danach ist das
programm zu ende also würde es irgendwie den unterschied machen also mal angenommen
das hier würde das hier das hier würde komplizieren irgendwann was nee was hier nicht gar nicht
komplett nee das ergibt doch keinen sinn verstehe den unterschied verstehe ich jetzt
an der stelle nicht also wenn einer kontrol c drückt dann wird das unterbrochen und danach
ist fertig wenn ihr drin irgendwie unbehandelte exception fliegt sing auch fertig glaube
ich jetzt sage weil schuh und dann drinne sage also was du meinst dass ich da tauchen
throw if cancellation requested macht das hier einen unterschied außer dass ich irgendeine
exception auf auf der im output sehe also hier müsste ich eine exception sehen wenn
ich kontrol c drücke bei den anderen beendet sich einfach hier sehe ich jetzt keinen unterschied
das muss eh parallel laufen noch also das ist das ist jetzt nicht so sinnvoll wie es
hier ist weil das führte jeden check nacheinander aus in wirklichkeit soll das ja alle checks
parallel ausführen also alle alle viertel stunde aber es funktioniert schon mal ganz
gut also es ist im prinzip so wie ich mir das so ich mir das vorgestellt habe jetzt
kommt natürlich jetzt kommt natürlich der schwierige part dass dieses komando zeilen
ding und drumherum und dass das an sich funktioniert ist ja das eine was wir jetzt was wir jetzt
machen müssen ist alle anbieter implementieren diese so eine api unterstützen also von hetzener
bis amazon bis google azure namcheap go daddy und alle möglichen dinge da kommen bestimmt
zu 15 bis 20 anbieter zusammen und vor allem das nicht die nächste frage die sich danach
stellt ist was machen wir wenn der anbieter keine api unterstützt
ich muss für jede für jedes unplugin erstellen was machen wir wenn der anbieter keine api
unterstützt dann müsste ich im hintergrund irgendwie webseiten scrapen oder so was
aber das funktioniert das schon mal nice basics tun ausloggen
wir machen mal hier aus und wir machen mal jetzt status jetzt kommet
blub beste jetzt push origin ja ok dass ich den kram mal gespeichert habe bei mir ja da
kann ich jetzt ein bisschen dran weiter basteln gleich oder die tage das heißt aber dass
es rein vom aufbau her funktioniert also es ist ein exporter es klappt jetzt für einen
anbieter zwar nur in der sandbox api aber es funktioniert
es macht geräusche was ist hier los ich glaube wackelkontakt fertig kein wackelkontakt mehr
ich werde so simpel machen wie wie bald bei dieser geschichte also ich baue mir da keine
eigene objekte für ich meine zwei zwei werte rausholen aus der response kann man auch hier
machen und was mich interessiert ist ja wirklich nur das hier ob ich seconds left überhaupt
rein mache weiß ich nicht weil das kann man sich im krafana selbst ausrechnen oder ich
glaube sogar schon mit dem prometor prometors query kann man selbst ausrechnen was würdest
du finde sie idee für sie scharp empfehlen es gibt must have extension von dem aber rider
ich kann die rider empfehlen ohne extensions einfach nur rider ohne irgendwas fertig beste
idee die es gibt vor allem weil sie cross platform ist mac windows linux so so ein blödsinn
wie visual studio von meck kannst du dir gleich sparen nimm rider oder noch besser kauft
ihr das jet brains all desktop pack das kostet 180 euro im monat wenn ich im monat im jahr
null aber ab dem zweiten jahr oder ab dem dritten jahr 180 euro im jahr und du hast
die kompletten jet brains produkte alle zusammen von 180 immer für das ist angemessen jet
brains all desktop pack kaufen für persönliche nutzung jährlich guck mal du bezahlst du
bezahlst oh das ist teurer geworden ok du bezahlst ab dem dritten jahr 173 auch inklusive
mehrwert steuer okay das ist aber viel teurer geworden ok du kannst auch nur du kannst
auch nur rider kaufen dann ist es billiger aber ich finde es geht trotzdem also 200 200
euro im jahr ich finde es immer noch ok ich finde es immer noch ok du kriegst die ganzen
du kriegst quasi alle ideen von denen ja und was rider alleine kostet muss man mal gucken
was cornered was kostet was kostet denn rider alleine rider ok rider alleine kostet nur
ab dem dritten jahr ok 89 euro ja ist ein bisschen ist ein bisschen billiger kostet
die hälfte vom all products pack
es ist ich finde es ist die beste ideen du kannst natürlich auch wishell studio nehmen
unter windows ist auch durchaus in ordnung wenn du windows unterwegs bist mac gibts wishell
studio von mac hab ich doch nie verwendet und unter linux gibts halt naja wishell studio
code wishell studio code ist für sie scharf zwar möglich aber nicht nicht so schön also
da ist mir rider deutlich lieber gratis nee was du machen kannst ist du kannst eine trial
du kannst eine trial version benutzen für 30 tage und du musst das halt mit deinem
account verknüpfen also musst du ja alle 30 tage einen neuen account machen früher
war das einfacher früher konntest du einfach die lizenz files löschen und eine unendlich
lange trial benutzen aber das geht nicht mehr mittlerweile haben sie das verknüpft mit
dem chatbrains account das geht leider leider leider kann man nicht mehr kann man nicht
mehr den trick mit der trial machen
aber es gibt nicht permanent beta version oder ist es nicht so dass es nur ab und zu
mal beta versionen gibt und die dann auch ablaufen wenn die wenn die released wird und
dann die nächste beta gibt es noch nicht da bin ich gar nicht sicher ob man das permanent
benutzen kann alle 40 tage sind betas invalid ja also ehrlich gesagt ich finde das nicht
nicht schlimm die die für das all all all desktop pack 180 euro im jahr ist ist echt
ok also das teuer ist ja auch gut das stimmt du kannst glaube ich wenn du student bist
gibt es das glaube ich kostenlos dazu brauchst du glaube ich ne edu ne edu email oder sowas
in der richtung also wenn du bekannten hast mit der edu email adresse aber jetzt go
so ich lösche mal ich lösche gerade mal mein account wieder wie löscht man dann
eigentlich sein account nicht sein out ok wie könnte man das erst mal gucken ob das
überhaupt geht wie kann man sein account wieder löschen
oh achtung hier name cheap summary brauchst einen ausweis ja meine edu adresse ist deutlich
einfacher zu bekommen als ein ausweis profil social media edit ein personal info kann man
den account überhaupt wieder löschen man weiß ja nie accounts security oder hier vielleicht
ja ist recht xs password changed pin schön dass es hier öffentlich da steht ja name cheap
delete account how do i cancel or close my account schreib an den support please submit
a ticket omega null ja dann halt nicht es ist eh nur ein sandbox account wen juckts
macht doch kein ticket ich mach den api access wieder aus und das und das war es und dann
lasse ich den account vergammeln so mit zack fertig ich werde mich da nie wieder einloggen
mein bankkonto juckts nein den juckts nicht das ist ein sandbox account da ist nichts
davon echt von dem was da drinnen war gut da würde ich sagen das reicht für heute
lange genug gebast all das man das da oben nicht drauf klicken kann triggert mich schon
irgendwie so ein bisschen das vielleicht ist wirklich kaputt alles klar zack ich habe
9000 euro aufgeladen ja so leute dann sehen wir uns im nächsten stream dreieinhalb stunden
fast reicht schon heute fertig aus ach stimmt ach stimmt wir wollten uns ja noch angucken
wie wir wollten ja noch auf die reaction reacten sample name dankeschön für den zapp wir
wollten ja noch auf die reaction react da habe ich jetzt überhaupt keinen antrieb und
energie mal grad dafür wir gucken uns das am anfang vom nächsten stream an ihr müsst
mich bloß nerven weil ich werde wahrscheinlich nächsten stream wieder sagen ach nee das machen
wir am ende vom stream und dann mache ich es am ende vom stream nicht ich gehe jetzt
auf leute wir sehen uns bis dann tschüss